* Sanfte Musik *
Auf einem abgelegenen See
im Westen von Kanada.
Hier beginnt sie,
unsere grosse Jubiläumsreise.
Zehn Jahre "Auf und davon" -
ganz herzlich willkommen!
Seit einem Jahrzehnt begleiten wir
Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
auf ihrer Suche nach Abenteuern
und einer neuen Heimat.
Ich bin momentan in Kanada unterwegs
und das ist kein Zufall,
denn Kanada ist
das "Auf und davon"-Land schlechthin.
An keinen anderen Ort haben wir
so viele begleitet wie hierhin.
U.a. denjenigen,
der mit mir im Boot sitzt:
Hermann Schönbächler.
Was haben wir vor, Hermann?
Wir fahren über den See,
um zu sehen,
wie das Gelände
auf der anderen Seite aussieht.
Wir fahren an einen Ort, der
wirklich einfach noch Kanada ist.
Was heisst das?
- Dass noch keiner da ist.
Ah, niemand ist da?
- Niemand ist da.
Du, ich und die Wildnis?
- Genau.
Wir gehen uns das mal ansehen.
Also: Was uns dort
auch immer erwartet -
wir werden es zusammen
mit Hermann herausfinden!
Wer ihn nicht kennt:
Hermann Schönbächler,
Holzfäller und Familienvater,
ist der bekannteste der Auswanderer
aus zehn Jahren "Auf und davon".
Er sagt, hier in Kanada sei er
seiner Bestimmung zugeführt worden.
* Lockere Musik *
Hermann hat
viele seiner Träume verwirklicht.
Aber einen gibt es noch:
ein Leben noch weiter ab vom Schuss,
komplett auf sich alleine gestellt.
Das wäre das Coolste,
das passieren könnte!
Für zehn Jahre "Auf und davon"
nimmt uns Hermann
in seine geliebte Wildnis mit.
Wir haben in dieser Jubiläumssendung
noch viel mehr für Sie bereit.
Auf einer grossen Reise
durch Westkanada
besuchen wir unsere Auswanderer
aus früheren Staffeln.
Wo seid ihr entwischt,
ihr blöden Tiere?
Jetzt seid ihr Hundefutter.
Nicht wahr?
Geschichten vom grossen Glück
und ebenso grossen Existenzängsten.
An jenem Abend,
als wir gehen mussten,
hatte ich mit dem Ganzen hier
abgeschlossen.
Als spezielles Zückerchen
zeigen wir heute
ganz neue Auswandererabenteuer.
Ja ...
- Schockiert.
Ja.
Sie konnten nicht nachvollziehen,
dass wir zu Hause
ein Stinktier haben.
Auswanderer,
die sich in den letzten zehn Jahren
von "Auf und davon" meldeten,
die wir aber nicht begleiten konnten.
Manchmal fühle ich mich auch einsam.
Ich alleine hier und kein Mensch,
der mich versteht.
Drei ganz neue Geschichten
von "Auf und davon".
Das war ein Bauchgefühl von mir.
Und das ist ja ein grosses Gefühl.
Und am Schluss
bringen wir einen Überraschungsgast
in den kanadischen Wald.
- Hasta la vista, baby!
Gölä, Sänger
des "Auf und davon"-Titelsongs,
trifft zum ersten Mal
auf Hermann Schönbächler.
Wo du recht hast, hast du recht.
- Ja.
Verdammter Mist!
Das ist zehn Jahre "Auf und davon".
# U si stige in Flüger,
flüged mit de Vögu furt.
# Chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie alles zrüg
uf dr Suechi für nes nois Dihei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Eifach uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
Rosswood, Westkanada.
Die Familie Schönbächler
lebt weit draussen.
Aber noch nicht weit genug
für Hermann.
Wer Kanada wirklich erleben wolle,
müsse hinaus in die Wildnis.
Und dort gehen wir jetzt hin.
Das hier nehmen wir mit.
Was ist das für eins?
- Das ist ...
... ein Husqvarna.
Das sagt mir überhaupt nichts,
aber es ist sicher tödlich.
Genau.
- Gut! Also, das nehmen wir mit.
Und ich bewaffne mich auch.
Mit einem Mückenmittel.
Das ist eben mein Ding.
Ich nehme keinen Spray mit.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist auch ein Mückenmittel.
- Creme?
Aber das kannst du einreiben.
V.a. ist es sehr praktisch,
wenn du
dein Geschäft erledigen musst.
Denn ...
Dann geht das folgendermassen:
Hosen runter ...
... die Oberschenkel ...
... Unterhosen runter ...
... Pobacken, das Zeug erledigen
und ganz schnell wieder ...
Und mit dem Spray
geht das jeweils so schlecht.
Hermann ist auf alles vorbereitet.
Und ich mache mich wohl besser
auf alles gefasst.
Wir ziehen zwei Tage
in den Wald hinaus.
Und zu Hause
passt Christine Schönbächler auf -
auch auf die drei Kinder Natascha ...
... Richi ...
... und Alexandra,
die gerade Ferien haben.
Wir sind von Rosswood
nach Norden gefahren, zum Sand Lake.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Hier, auf der anderen Seeseite,
liegen Hunderte Quadratkilometer Wald
vor uns.
Nichts als Wald.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui!
Ist das eine Sauerei hier!
So sieht also das Kanada aus, in dem
Hermann am liebsten leben würde:
in einem Blockhaus in der Wildnis,
wie die Pioniere früher.
Wäre das dein Ziel,
völlig unabhängig zu sein?
Das wäre das Coolste,
das passieren könnte!
Warum?
Sicher?
Habe ich eine Hirnzelle
mehr oder weniger
oder mir als Kind den Kopf
öfter als du gestossen?
Ich habe das einfach hier drin.
Schon als kleiner Junge verschlang
Hermann Bücher über die Wildnis.
Wow.
Was ihn an der einsamen Natur
so fasziniert
und wie er irgendwann
gerne leben würde,
genau das
will uns Hermann jetzt zeigen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es geht immer tiefer in den Wald.
Keine Ahnung, wo wir landen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Endlich finden wir
einen Platz für unser Basislager.
Also ich glaube, schöner hätte man es
sich nicht vorstellen können.
Was meinst du?
- Ei, ei, ei, ei, ei!
Es ist etwas klein.
- Klein?
Es gibt eine Sauerei
mit alten Bäumen.
Na gut, das können wir ja aufräumen.
- Das müssen wir aufräumen, ja.
* Sanfte Musik *
Du stehst auf der falschen Seite.
- Scheibe!
* Sie stöhnt. *
So!
- Eins, zwei, drei!
* Sanfte Musik *
Nachher kommt das so hin.
Die musst du nicht hier durchziehen.
Bist du zufrieden?
Also ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Ich glaube, ich könnte es mir
nicht schöner vorstellen.
So!
Komme ich an solche Plätze,
will ich gleich bleiben.
Also wäre das ein Platz,
wo du ein Haus aufstellen würdest?
Nein.
Nicht?
- Nein.
Aber schöner findest du es nirgendwo.
Du willst hier
kein halbbatziges Häuschen haben.
Das willst du dort hinten
an einem Ort im Wald verstecken.
Also was? Wegen des Windes?
Ja, wegen des Windes,
wegen der Kälte,
einfach
wegen der miesen Wettereinflüsse.
Aha!
Hast du Hunger?
- Ja.
Wollen wir etwas essen?
* Sanfte Musik *
Als Notvorrat hat Hermann
zu Hause Nudelsuppe eingepackt.
Aber ich hätte wissen müssen,
dass das alleine
einem wie ihm nicht reicht.
* Sanfte Musik *
Jetzt hast du ihn! Jetzt hast du ihn.
Und jetzt ... Hopp!
Uh!
* Sie stöhnt. *
So!
Imbiss.
Ah, das muss man da hinlegen?
Trockene Äste und Flechten
von den Bäumen als Zunder -
und dann packt Hermann
seinen Magnesiumfeuerstarter aus.
Wieso nimmst du nicht einfach
ein Feuerzeug mit?
Das wäre einfacher.
Wenn ein Gasfeuerzeug nass ist,
funktioniert es nicht.
Das funktioniert auch,
wenn es nass ist.
Siehst du, wie es reagiert,
wenn das Magnesium ankommt?
Ich bin überzeugt.
* Knistern *
Aus der Forelle
will Hermann eine Fischsuppe kochen.
Ich muss aufpassen,
dass ich keine Viecher mitnehme.
So!
- Und dieses Wasser hier ...
Kann man das trinken - aus diesem ...
Das sollte man so, wie es
hier drin ist, nicht trinken.
Denn hier, an all diesen Orten,
wo Biber wohnen,
gibt es ein Bakterium,
das dir Magen und Darm
durchputzen kann.
Man nennt das Biberfieber.
Biberfieber?
* Mona lacht. *
Es ist einfach ... Es ist ein
Durchfall von der schlimmsten Sorte.
Wenn du dir das einfängst,
musst du im Spital an den Tropf.
* Sanfte Musik *
Zum Glück reichen aber fünf Minuten
Kochen, um die Biberkeime abzutöten.
* Sanfte Musik *
Leben und überleben in der Natur
muss Hermann nicht mehr lernen.
Schon als junger Mann
reiste er wochenlang
durch Kanada und Alaska -
ganz alleine.
* Sanfte Musik *
Was einfach ist: Wenn du
alleine unterwegs bist und ...
Du kommst als ...
... junger Mann,
der eigentlich lieber
mit seiner Partnerin
als mutterseelenallein reisen würde,
an einen solchen Ort.
Du kannst ihn mit niemandem teilen.
Und so geht das weiter.
Tag für Tag für Tag für Tag.
Du siehst die schönsten Dinge.
Du siehst das, worauf du
seit Teenagerzeiten wartest.
Aber du kannst es
mit niemandem teilen.
Das macht dich fertig.
Das macht dich fertig!
Darum steht in
der menschlichen Gebrauchsanleitung,
dass der liebe Gott
Männlein und Weiblein gemacht hat.
Das ist ja ganz logisch, oder?
- Um es teilen zu können.
Ja. Ja.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Die grosse Liebe,
mit der er alles teilen kann,
fand Hermann Schönbächler
in seiner Frau Christine.
Sie ist ebenso begeistert von der
Natur und von Kanada im Speziellen.
Es passt perfekt.
Nur einmal im Leben machte Hermann
einen grösseren Fang
als mit Christine.
Hey, das ist unser Zuhause!
Zu ihrem grössten Abenteuer
brechen die beiden im Jahr 2010 auf.
Sie wandern aus -
von Biel nach Kanada.
Versuch es mal!
# Ta-ta-ta-ta!
- So!
Die Schuhe abklopfen!
Kostenpunkt des Hauses: 250'000 Fr.
Die Reise war lang -
und am Ende wartet ein unmöbliertes,
kaltes Haus auf die kranke Natascha.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Die Familie macht sich vertraut
mit der neuen Umgebung.
Jetzt geht er weg.
Er hat sich natürlich erschrocken.
Wir haben einen Elch gesehen.
- Genau.
Das sind ganz kleine, leichte Mäuse.
Sie kommen hier drauf -
und zack, die Falle schnappt zu.
Nachher ist die Maus ...
- ... tot.
Kaputt. Kaputt.
- Tot!
Nein, es ist gut, Richi.
Der gelernte Forstwart
Hermann Schönbächler
hat eine Anstellung
als Holzfäller erhalten.
Sein Boss ist angetan von den Fähig-
keiten seines neuen Mitarbeiters.
Wow.
- Well, am I getting the job?
* Lachen *
Wow!
Von nun an kann die Familie
Schönbächler ihre Abenteuerlust
direkt vor der Haustür ausleben.
* Jauchzen *
Allerdings: Das Boot hält mit der
Euphorie von Hermann nicht ganz mit.
Oh nein!
- Und jetzt?
Oje! Ist die Turbine voller Sand?
Ah, dort ist ein Bär?
- Ja.
Okay.
- Ja, ich rede von diesem Bären.
Ich habe nicht gewusst,
dass du ihn nicht siehst.
Ich realisiere nichts.
* Richi weint. *
Warum weinst du denn, Richi?
Warum hast du denn Angst, Richi?
Wovor?
Vor dem Bären.
Vor dem Bären?
- Ja.
Du meine Güte!
Anfang Sommer
kommt jeweils der Bart ab.
Ein Ritual, das Hermann mit
den Jahren aber bleiben lassen wird.
Er zeigt die Zähne.
Das sieht
wieder 20 Jahre jünger aus.
* Pfeifen des Windes *
Am 10.10.2010 kommt jene Nacht,
die Familie Schönbächler
nie mehr vergessen wird.
Ein Jahrhundertsturm zieht auf.
Bäume knicken wie Zündhölzer
und drohen auf das neue Zuhause
der Schönbächlers zu fallen.
Oh, nur nicht aufs Gästehaus! Nein!
Das Haus
bleibt zum Glück unbeschädigt.
Aber die Zerstörung im Wald
ist riesig.
Das hier war mal ein Wald.
Das war ein Wald
mit grossen, hohen Bäumen.
Hier steht kein einziger mehr.
Kein einziger mehr.
Jetzt weiss ich, warum es
letzte Nacht dermassen krachte.
Du meine Güte!
Nein! Ojemine!
* Ein Baby schreit. *
Nur zwei Monate später
gibt es Erfreulicheres zu berichten:
Die Familie Schönbächler
ist komplett.
Das ist Alexandra.
Heute vor einer Woche
kam sie zur Welt.
Wir haben uns eigentlich schon lange
nochmals ein Kind gewünscht.
Und wegen des ganzen Umzugs und so
wollten wir das eigentlich
nicht unbedingt. Und ... ja.
Jetzt durften wir hier in Kanada
eine kleine Kanadierin bekommen.
Das ist schön!
Oh ja!
Willst du zu Daddy kommen?
Ja. Mhm!
Hermann im Glück.
Der Baumfäller
weiss sein Gefühl der Freude
in ein kerniges Lebensmotto
zu giessen.
Das ist wirklich genial!
Das, was wir hier haben,
ist die ultimative Lebensqualität.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auch fünf Jahre später
ist die Verwüstung des Sturmes
noch deutlich sichtbar.
Doch die Naturkatastrophe
hat auch ihr Gutes:
Dank der vielen, brachliegenden Bäume
konnten sich Schönbächlers als
Holzlieferanten selbstständig machen.
In der nächstgelegenen Stadt Terrace
gehen die beiden Kinder Richi
und Natascha mittlerweile zur Schule.
Sie haben einen sehr langen Schulweg
von drei Stunden.
Die fünfjährige Alexandra
ist noch zu Hause.
Die Schönbächlers
haben es sich gut eingerichtet.
Doch ein kleiner Funken Abenteuerlust
scheint noch nicht gestillt.
Mein ultimativer Traum wäre es,
vielleicht schon mal eine Zeit lang
ganz weit draussen zu sein.
* Sanfte Musik *
Und auf den Spuren
dieses ultimativen Traums,
den Hermann und Christine träumen,
sind wir jetzt.
Hier im Wald mit Hermann.
Weit weg von der Zivilisation.
Einsam.
Nur wir und ein paar Mücken,
die hoffnungsvoll
um unsere Köpfe kreisen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wenn hier draussen
die Sonne untergeht, wird es Zeit,
sich hinzulegen.
Wo putzt du dir die Zähne?
Die putze ich dann zu Hause wieder.
Die Zähne?
- Ja.
Nein, aber man muss sich doch
die Zähne putzen!
Hat dir das die Zahnputzfrau
nie gesagt?
Ich bin ein Buschmann.
Die putzen sich die Zähne nicht?
Nein.
- Nicht?
Hast du etwa Zahnpasta dabei?
- Natürlich habe ich Zahnpasta dabei.
Du warst noch nie unterwegs,
wenn ich unterwegs war.
Nein, das nimmst du nicht mit.
Das brauchst du nicht.
Das ist nicht überlebensnotwendig.
- Ja, aber ...
Nein, nicht überlebensnotwendig,
aber ...
Ja, vielleicht ...
Für den Selbstrespekt
ist es doch noch wichtig,
dass man sich die Zähne putzt.
Das hat mit Selbstrespekt
nichts zu tun.
Vielleicht mit dem Respekt
vor dem Gegenüber.
Ich weiss es nicht. Also,
du putzt deine Zähne nicht? Okay!
Wenn ich draussen campiere,
putze ich mir die Zähne nicht.
Also, das ist gut.
Hermann hat sein Zelt etwas
weiter hinten im Wald aufgebaut.
Vor Bären müsse ich in der Nacht
keine Angst haben, hat er gesagt.
In dieser Jahreszeit gebe es keine -
normalerweise.
Ah, das Gewehr ist bei dir?
Es schläft bei dir?
Ja.
Ja, das ist gut. Also schlaf gut!
Danke gleichfalls!
- Gute Nacht!
* Sanfte Musik *
Während wir im Wald
langsam einschlafen,
herrscht in Rosswood grosse Aufregung
- und zwar wegen eines Bären.
Christine Schönbächler
hat via Facebook erfahren,
dass bei einem Nachbar
ein Bär herumschleiche -
und zwar nicht irgendeiner,
sondern ein Kermode,
ein ganz besonderes Tier.
Wenigstens anschnallen,
wenn ich schon keinen Ausweis habe.
Das ist einer
dieser weissen Schwarzbären,
die wir hier in der Gegend haben.
Ganz selten
ist einer dieser Bären weiss.
Also ich habe ihn bisher
erst zweimal gesehen.
Und darum
ist das etwas richtig Spezielles.
Jetzt sind wir bald neun Jahre hier
und ich habe ihn
erst zweimal gesehen.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
Er war hier.
Derjenige, der ihn fotografiert hat,
war auf der Seite
und hat ihn dort drüben abgelichtet.
Vielleicht sitzt er
bei ihm vor der Tür.
Dort bewegt sich etwas.
Da ist etwas im Gebüsch.
Schau mal! Das ist er tatsächlich!
Er ist so gut versteckt im Gebüsch.
Der Bär lässt sich beim Fressen
von Beeren nicht stören.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
- Nein, so toll!
Bei den Ureinwohnern
war der weisse Bär heilig.
Es heisst, er bringe jenen Glück,
die ihn sehen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Bei uns draussen im Buschcamp
blieb alles ruhig.
* Sanfte Musik *
Aber es wurde ziemlich kalt.
Ich versuche, Feuer zu machen.
Der Outdoor-Chef schläft noch.
* Sanfte Musik *
Meine Survival-Skills reichen schon
für einen warmen Haferbrei
und für einen Buschkaffee
für Hermann.
Und ich halte noch etwas
für ihn bereit.
Heute
ist ein spezieller Tag für Hermann.
Hermann hat nämlich Geburtstag -
wie "Auf und davon".
* Sie summt die Melodie
von "Happy Birthday". *
Hermann,
alles, alles Gute zum Geburtstag!
Vielen, vielen Dank!
Aber schau:
Der Wind hat deine Kerze ausgeblasen.
Wir zünden sie nochmals an.
So!
- So!
Vielen Dank! Das ist aber lustig.
Schau mal!
Heute ist kein Tag wie jeder andere.
Genau.
Jetzt bist du 52.
Richtig, ja.
Merkst du das schon ein bisschen?
Du ...
Ich merke einfach, dass ich mein
Leben lang hart gearbeitet habe.
Dann schmerzt mich morgens
zuerst das Fussgelenk,
dann das Knie.
Nachher schmerzt mich
das andere Knie und Fussgelenk.
Nachher schmerzt der Ellbogen.
Das ist das, was ich spüre.
- Ja.
Jetzt habe ich hier einen kleinen
Cupcake in den Kanada-Farben.
Es gibt nichts, was es nicht gibt.
Extra für dich.
Unglaublich!
Ich hoffe, er schmeckt auch.
- Das hier ist ...
100 km draussen im Busch.
Das ist Service!
Mmh!
* Sanfte Musik *
Hermann feiert seinen Geburtstag nie.
Er gehe einfach fischen
oder alleine in den Wald.
Dieses Jahr hat er halt noch mich
im Schlepptau.
Das ist Wolfsdreck.
- Ja.
Es gibt welche.
Aber ich weiss nicht, wie viele.
Hast du noch nie einen gesehen?
- Doch, doch.
Hier draussen gehören Begegnungen
mit wilden Tieren dazu.
Hermann geht mit ihnen
auf seine eigene Art um.
Bei den Schwarzbären, die ich
im Bereich von so 20, 50 m antreffe,
bleibe ich meistens einfach stehen
und beginne, mit ihnen zu reden.
Ich rühme ihn,
wenn er niedlich und lieb ist
und sicher keinen Hunger
und keine Lust hat,
mit etwas zu spielen.
Und dass du ihm nicht sein
Territorium streitig machen willst.
Ja, aber das machst du?
Das sagst du alles?
Ja.
Und dann gehst du langsam rückwärts.
Verstehen die Bären Schweizerdeutsch?
Offensichtlich.
Dann sieht man einander einfach an.
Und meistens ... äh ... meistens ...
Der Intelligentere gibt dann nach.
Das ist meistens der Bär.
* Sanfte Musik *
Der Grund,
warum wir durch das Gehölz stolpern:
Hermann sucht einen Platz, an dem er
sein Blockhaus bauen könnte.
Das sieht ja alles gleich aus.
- Das sieht alles gleich aus.
Aber haben sich in diesen riesigen
Wäldern auch schon Leute verlaufen?
Ja.
Sie waren wochenlang verschollen.
Die Wölfe und Kojoten
putzten sie weg.
Sie wurden nie gefunden.
Hermann sucht fruchtbaren Boden.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
- Zu wenig Erde.
Ja.
Es hat ein bisschen.
Wer hier ein Haus bauen will,
muss sich
auch selber ernähren können.
Ja ...
Das sieht ein bisschen mager aus.
Wir sind unterwegs wie die Pioniere,
die sich schon vor 100 Jahren
davonmachten
und die kanadische Wildnis
besiedelten.
Rohhumus auf Steinen.
Hermann gibt nicht auf, im Gegenteil.
Ich habe das Gefühl:
Je länger er sucht,
umso ernster wird es ihm damit,
hier draussen mitten in der Wildnis
eine Heimat zu haben.
Aber würde es dich reizen?
- Extrem, extrem, extrem.
Das zieht mich so richtig rein.
Du machst das nicht nur,
um mir das zu zeigen.
Eigentlich
bist du jetzt auf der Suche.
Ja.
Das ist mir
richtig ins Blut gegangen.
Also!
Komm, graben wir noch
am einen oder anderen Ort!
Gräbst du noch ein bisschen?
Also dein Beil ist nicht dazu da,
um es in den Boden zu schlagen.
Das ist
eine rasiermesserscharfe Klinge,
die man nur dazu benutzt,
um einen kleinen Baum zu hacken.
Ja, ist gut! Hast du mir angesehen,
dass ich auch graben wollte?
Das gefällt mir.
- Guter Humus. Dunkle Erde.
Hier könnte man etwas machen.
Das ist ein schöner Flecken.
Möchtest du einen fällen?
Jawohl.
So!
Genau hier hast du einen Meter.
Das Pionierfieber hat ihn gepackt.
Jetzt will Hermann den Grundriss
eines Blockhauses auslegen.
Quasi als Geburtstagsgeschenk
an sich selber.
Jetzt kommt er.
- Tipptopp, tipptopp!
Genau dort wollte ich ihn.
Zwischen diesen Bäumen?
- Jawohl.
Drei auf drei Meter seien die meisten
Häuser der alten Siedler gewesen.
Hermann schätzt, dass er 14 Tage
für den Bau des Blockhauses braucht.
Anders als in einem Schweizer Wald,
kümmert sich hier niemand darum,
dass wir soeben
einen Baum gefällt haben.
Gut.
So!
Jetzt hat man eine Vorstellung.
Das wäre
die quadratische Grundfläche.
Das wäre genau die Grundfläche -
quadratisch.
Da muss man aber viele fällen.
- Ja, ja.
Das Blockhaus ist ausgelegt.
Damit auch das Fundament von Hermanns
Traum von einem Leben in der Wildnis,
den er seit der Kindheit
in sich trägt.
Wenn wir euch in zehn Jahren
wieder besuchen kommen:
Leben du und Stine auf einem selbst
gerodeten Stück Land in der Wildnis?
In zehn Jahren
sind wir noch am gleichen Ort.
Leider oder zum Glück?
Der Umstände wegen.
Wir haben drei Kinder,
denen wir
ein sicheres Zuhause geben wollen.
Aber wenn die Kinder später
weg sind und ich noch fit bin,
dann sicher.
* Sanfte Musik *
Hermann traue ich es auch absolut zu,
dass er sich irgendwann hier draussen
eine Altersresidenz baut.
Aber fürs Erste geht es zurück
zu Hof und Familie nach Rosswood.
Hallo, Stine.
- Hallo.
Schön, bist du zurück.
Hallihallo. Wie geht's? Hallo, Richi.
Gibt's für dich nun auch eine Dusche?
- Zuerst etwas zu essen.
Richi macht Pancakes.
Das ist sehr lecker, Richi. Super.
Gesprächsthema Nummer 1
ist Christines Begegnung
mit dem Kermodebär.
Zuerst sahen wir ihn gar nicht.
Nur das Gebüsch bewegte sich.
Deshalb musste dort etwas sein.
An Tagen wie heute
ist das Zuhause der Schönbächlers
wie ein Abenteuerspielplatz,
auf dem sich jeder ausleben kann.
Das meint Hermann wohl mit
der "ultimativen Lebensqualität".
Sie versorgen sich
grösstenteils selbst -
mit Fleisch, Eiern, Gemüse und Obst.
Die Himbeerenernte
braucht im Sommer am meisten Zeit.
Es sind Sommerferien
und die Kinder helfen mit.
Wenn die Ferien um sind,
geht nur noch die Jüngste, Alexandra,
zurück in die Schule nach Terrace.
Alles ist in der Spülmaschine.
Beim Pesto-Machen berichtet Christine
von der Neuigkeit der Schönbächlers:
Natascha und Richi gehen nicht mehr
an die öffentliche Schule.
Sie werden zu Hause unterrichtet.
Hilfst du uns auch noch?
Nach den Ferien
gehst du nicht mehr zur Schule, oder?
Dann machst du Homeschooling?
- Ja.
Warum?
Ich will Homeschooling,
weil ich in der Schule nichts lerne.
In der Schule lernst du nichts?
Aber dann
siehst du deine Freund nicht mehr.
Nicht so oft, aber das macht nichts.
Das macht nichts. Sicher?
Das verwundert mich.
Für Kinder in diesem Alter
sind die Freunde sehr wichtig.
Das ist so.
- Machst du dir keine Gedanken?
Doch, natürlich.
Freunde sind wichtig.
Er spielt auch gerne.
Aber er hat auch in Rosswood
Freunde.
Hier gibt es auch Kinder.
Dann muss man sich
am Wochenende mit ihnen treffen.
Wegen den grossen Distanzen
ist Homeschooling in Kanada
verbreiteter als bei uns.
Sie arbeiten mit einem Lehrer,
der auch Aufgaben kontrolliert.
So gibt es
einen kanadischen Schulabschluss.
Sie haben es nicht aktiv gesucht,
sagt Christine.
Ab der Oberstufe sei das Lerntempo
hier langsamer als in der Schweiz.
Das frustrierte Natascha immer mehr.
Sie lernt seit einem Jahr zu Hause.
Der Entscheid
ist euch aber nicht leichtgefallen.
Nein. Auch bei Natascha
war es ein langer Prozess.
Sie wurde in der Schule
immer unglücklicher.
Wir mussten etwas machen,
weil es so nicht weiterging.
Manchmal ist es auch anstrengend,
Kinder im Haus zu haben.
Wärst du manchmal froh, wenn du sie
mehr nach draussen schicken könntest?
Ehrlich gesagt, ja.
Aber sie ist viel glücklicher so.
Manchmal
ist sie auch eine gute Hilfe.
Das ist auch schön.
Ich habe nicht Kinder,
damit ich sie wegschicken kann.
Man lebt und arbeitet zusammen.
Man wächst auch zusammen.
Schönbächlers
geniessen die gemeinsame Zeit -
bis die Kinder irgendwann
ihren eigenen Träumen folgen
und ausfliegen.
Für mich wird es Zeit, aufzubrechen.
Zum Zehn-Jahres-Jubiläum
von "Auf und davon" wollen wir
auch unsere drei anderen Aus-
wandererfamilien in Kanada besuchen.
Eine grosse Reise, die mich
wieder zurück zu Schönbächlers führt.
Alles Gute.
- Es war schön, dich hier zu haben.
Am Ende unserer Kanadatour
komme ich nochmals
und bringe euch jemanden mit.
- Okay.
Surprise, surprise.
- Das ist gut. Bye-bye.
Tschüss!
* Sanfte Musik *
Wenn die wüssten,
wer sie noch besucht.
Unser Überraschungsgast ist seit
Beginn bei "Auf und davon" dabei.
Er hat die Sendung mitgeprägt,
aber nicht als Auswanderer,
sondern mit seiner Musik.
Er ist der,
der im Titelsong "Uf u dervo"
das Gefühl von Fernweh und Wegwollen
einfach perfekt einfängt:
Es ist Gölä.
# Ines Land ohni Näbu, ohni Räge,
ines Land, wo si Sunne hei.
# I gieng hüt no uf u dervo.
# Eifach uf u dervo.
Bevor wir Schönbächlers
mit Gölä überraschen,
besuche ich Familie Fischer, die
2014 bei "Auf und davon" dabei war,
Familie Volk aus der achten Staffel
und Familie Ruckstuhl, die wir vor
drei Jahren in der Sendung hatten.
Im Rosswood General Store,
dem einzigen Laden weit und breit,
kaufe ich Proviant.
Hi.
In diesem Laden
findet man alles Nötige zum Leben.
Ein Regal
hat etwas weniger Lebenswichtiges.
Wow!
Das ist alles Feuerwerk.
Ist das Ihre Spezialität?
Ja, wenn man Pilze sammelt,
kann man damit Bären verjagen,
oder sie vom Land treiben.
Wow! Dann erschreckt man den Bären
mit einem Riesenknaller?
Nein, aber das könnte man.
Ein kleines Feuerwerk reicht auch.
Okay.
Feuerwerk, um Bären zu verjagen.
Wieder etwas über Kanadier und
ihren Umgang mit der Wildnis gelernt.
Jetzt ist es Zeit, um über den
kanadischen Tellerrand zu blicken.
Seit zehn Jahren
begleitet "Auf und davon" Menschen,
die auf der Suche nach Abenteuer
oder einer neuen Heimat sind.
In dieser Zeit haben sich bei uns
hunderte Menschen beworben.
Begleiten konnten wir aber
nur einen kleinen Teil.
Eine Jubiläumssendung
ist der ideale Anlass,
um bei einigen der anderen
nachzufragen,
ob sie ihren Traum
verwirklicht haben.
Wenn wir in diesen zehn Jahren
etwas gelernt haben, dann das:
Es kommt nie so,
wie man es geplant hat.
Aber dass es so anders wie bei
Familie Flury kommt, ist speziell.
Familie Flury:
Das sind Catherine und Christopher,
mit ihren drei Kindern
Anja, Sämi und Janis.
Eine ganz normale Familie,
könnte man meinen.
Vor sieben Jahren trafen wir sie
zum Casting in Neuheim im Kanton Zug.
Wenn wir damals gewusst hätten,
was die Flurys für Abenteuer erleben,
hätten wir sie
schon früher begleitet.
Warum auswandern?
Weil wir etwas Neues erleben wollen.
Weil wir den Eindruck haben,
dass wir privat und geschäftlich
in Australien
mehr Möglichkeiten haben.
Wir sagen uns immer wieder,
dass wir etwas Neues machen müssen.
Ich war auch schon in Australien
und es fasziniert mich einfach.
Weisst du, wo Australien ist?
- Nein.
Mhm.
Wo ist es?
- Unten.
Unten?
Gehen wir dann kopfüber?
- Ja.
Oben. Oben Himmel.
- Oben im Himmel ist Australien?
Ja!
Welche Tiere aus Australien
kennst du?
Känguru.
Bei Krokodilen muss man aufpassen,
dass sie dich nicht beissen.
Janis, gibt es dort Schlangen?
- Ja!
Australien ist ihr grosser Traum.
Die Flurys verkaufen ihr Haus
und ihre Reinigungsfirma.
Doch plötzlich
ziehen sie die Reissleine.
Sie blasen Australien ab.
Wir wussten nie,
wann das Visum kommt.
Plötzlich ging es darum,
wie es weitergeht.
Die Neuen wollten einziehen
und wir mussten raus.
Dann entschieden wir uns ...
- ... etwas anderes anzuschauen.
Per Zufall kam ich
durch einen Kunden von uns,
bei dem wir die Umzugsreinigung
machten, auf Uruguay.
Er erzählte mir dann von Uruguay.
Ich dachte nur: Wo ist das?
* Sanfte Musik *
Uruguay. Catherine und Christopher
wissen gar nichts über dieses Land.
Trotzdem entscheiden sie sich,
eine Woche nach Südamerika zu reisen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Was wir dort sahen,
gefiel uns extrem gut.
Wir konnten uns gut vorstellen,
dorthin zu ziehen.
Dann machten wir das.
In den fünf Tagen
fanden wir bereits ein Haus.
Ja.
- Ja.
In kürzester Zeit
kauften wir ein Haus.
Wir krempelten unsere Pläne um
und wanderten Ende April
nach Uruguay aus.
Es ist das Jahr 2013.
Familie Flury hat nach dem Verkauf
von Haus und Firma genug Geld,
um längere Zeit
ohne Einkünfte auszukommen.
Alle geniessen die Zeit in Uruguay.
Die Kinder gehen zur Schule
und sind schnell integriert.
Und auch die einheimischen Tiere
hinterlassen
einen bleibenden Eindruck.
Ein Baby-Stinktier
läuft der Familie zu.
Am Anfang
spritzte er mich etwa dreimal an,
weil sie sehr schreckhaft sind.
Er hebt den Schwanz und spritzt.
Dann spritzt es kleine Tropfen,
die stinken.
Schlimm!
- Es ist intensiv.
Er wurde aber immer zahmer, weil
er merkte, dass es ihm gut geht.
Wir hielten ihn im Haus
und man konnte ihn rufen.
Dann kam er und lief dir nach.
Den Uruguayern
konnten wir nicht sagen,
dass wir ein Stinktier als Haustier
haben. Die waren schockiert.
Sie konnten das mit dem Stinktier
nicht nachvollziehen.
Flurys sind glücklich in Uruguay.
Endlich haben sie Zeit für sich.
Es gibt nur ein Problem:
Catherine und Christopher finden
keine Möglichkeit zu arbeiten.
Nach drei Jahren kam die Langeweile.
- Es wurde langweilig.
Irgendwann hat man alles gemacht,
was man wollte.
Dann ist es vorbei.
Wir sind aktive Menschen.
Wir mögen neue Herausforderungen.
Deshalb sagten wir,
dass wir weitermüssen.
Ja.
Christopher und ich gingen
eine knappe Woche nach Florida.
Wir schauten, ob das etwas wäre.
Mhm.
Dann war es etwas.
So ziehen die Flurys
in die Vereinigten Staaten -
ins sonnige Florida.
Aber nicht ans Meer,
sondern ins Hinterland.
Hier liegt das Rentnerparadies
schlechthin: The Villages.
Die Stadt wurde speziell für Rentner
aus dem Boden gestampft -
inklusive Strassen für Golfwagen.
Zehntausende Rentner
leben in The Villages.
Die nächste grössere Ortschaft
heisst Lady Lake.
* Beschwingter Soulsong:
"Respect" von Aretha Franklin *
Mitten im Altersheim von Amerika:
die Auswandererfamilie Flury
mit ihren drei Kindern.
Guten Appetit.
Wenn sie uns fragen, wo wir wohnen,
sagen wir, bei Lady Lake.
Dann sagen sie: "Aber das ist doch
bei The Villages, bei den Alten."
Sie sehen das so,
aber ich empfinde das nicht so.
Ich finde, es hat viele Vorteile,
weil alles sehr gepflegt
und ordentlich ist.
Es gibt viele schöne Geschäfte
zum Shoppen und schöne Restaurants.
Das ist für uns
ein grosser Pluspunkt, ja.
Die Familie
wohnt ausserhalb von Lady Lake.
Statt in Australien nach Uruguay
und weiter nach Florida.
Die Flurys stellten gleich mehrmals
alles auf den Kopf.
Was trieb sie an,
ihr Leben so radikal umzukrempeln?
Wir haben beide
unsere Mutter verloren.
Wir wussten, dass man nicht
zur Pensionierung warten kann.
Da sagten wir: "Wenn wir uns etwas
erfüllen und etwas sehen möchten,
dann müssen wir es jetzt machen."
Wir wollten nicht warten,
bis die Kinder gross sind,
um dann alleine
auf Reisen zu gehen.
* Ruhige Instrumentalklänge *
Der Garten der Flurys ist fast
so gross wie drei Fussballfelder -
Seeanstoss inklusive.
Alligatoren
sollen sich auch darin tummeln.
Von Nachbarn keine Spur.
Tagwacht um 7 Uhr.
Für die Pausenbrote
ist Papa Christopher zuständig.
Wie viel Zeit habe ich noch?
- Keine, wir müssen gehen.
Die Ernährerin der Familie
ist jetzt Catherine.
Christopher
wollte lieber zu Hause sein.
Ich wollte gerne etwas machen.
Es ist traumhaft,
dass ich ein Geschäft führen darf.
Christopher schaut zu den Kindern
und macht den Haushalt.
Ich kann mich voll
auf das Geschäft konzentrieren.
Diese Möglichkeit haben nicht alle.
Catherine arbeitete
schon seit frühester Jugend
im Restaurant ihrer Eltern mit
und lernte Hotelfachfrau.
Jetzt hat sie ein eigenes Geschäft:
eine Eisdiele.
Sie bezahlte 99'000 Dollar und
erhielt dafür ein laufendes Business.
Das Eis stellt sie nicht selber her.
Sie kauft es ein.
Ich kontrolliere, was fehlt.
"Superman" und "Cotton Candy" -
die sind bei Kindern sehr beliebt.
Catherines Angestellte
sind alles Frauen -
die meisten Studentinnen.
Das Geschäft ist gewinnbringend
und sichert der Familie
die Aufenthaltserlaubnis in den USA.
Während Catherine
die Brötchen verdient,
schmeisst Christopher den Haushalt.
Es macht mir nicht viel aus.
Aber es ist eine never-ending Story.
Nach einer Wäsche
kommt schon die nächste.
Christopher
musste erst darum kämpfen,
den Haushalt so führen zu können,
wie  e r  will und kann.
Am Anfang
war das Problem in der Küche.
Wenn ich koche, mache ich das
anders, aber ich komme zum Ziel.
Wenn sie nach der Arbeit hier war
und ich noch kochte,
sagte sie immer,
wie ich es machen sollte.
Dann musste ich sagen: "Raus aus
der Küche! Das mache ich jetzt."
Sie musste damit klarkommen,
wie ich es mache.
Das hat sich mit der Zeit
gut eingespielt.
Das ist kein Thema mehr.
Die Kinder gehen
an die öffentliche Primarschule.
Seit zwei Jahren in den USA, kommen
sie mit Englisch schon gut zurecht.
Like, super-duper fast like Flash.
Right?
Sämi und seine Schwester Anja
gehen beide in die fünfte Klasse.
Look at that!
Catherine
hat gleich neben der Eisdiele
sogar ein zweites Geschäft
übernommen.
Die Spezialität beim Sandwichladen
"Let's-do": Hummer im Brot.
Die Flurys wollen nicht mehr
von Ersparnissen leben,
sondern von ihrem Einkommen -
damit sie auch im Alter
noch Rücklagen haben.
Wir leben gut und müssen nicht gross
auf das Geld schauen.
Wir können oft auswärts essen gehen.
Wir achten nicht auf den Einkauf.
Christopher kauft ein.
Ich gebe auch kein Budget vor.
Es ist alles okay.
Auch Christopher hat mittlerweile
einen kleinen Verdienst.
To the band?
- Cut them just like those.
Seit Kurzem arbeitet er
bei einer biologischen Baumschule.
Nicht, weil er muss,
sondern, weil er will.
Sein Chef ist ein Franzose.
Unter Europäern seien die Menta-
litätsunterschiede weniger gross,
sagt Christopher.
Wir Schweizer sind sehr bescheiden.
Wir sind sehr bescheiden.
So wurden wir erzogen. Das ist so.
Damit hat man im Ausland
manchmal Probleme,
weil man oft
die Ellbogen auspacken muss.
Damit hat man etwas Mühe,
weil wir nicht so aufgewachsen sind.
Da muss man sich durchbeissen,
dann geht das schon.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wenn die Kinder um 15.30 Uhr
von der Schule kommen,
ist Mamma Catherine
bereits wieder zu Hause.
Hallo, Anja.
Sie ist stolz
auf die Leistungen ihrer Sprösslinge.
Sie haben schnell Englisch gelernt.
Das Spanisch haben sie leider
in der Zwischenzeit fast verloren.
Ja, sie haben sich
sehr gut integriert.
Was hast du
bei den Multiplikationen?
3'580.
700.
- Was? 700?
Seid ihr bei der gleichen Aufgabe?
Ich habe die falsche Zahl genommen!
Ich nahm die Zwei statt der Vier.
* Ruhige Instrumentalklänge *
Die Flurys bereiten in ihrem
riesigen Garten ein Barbecue vor.
* Motorsäge stoppt. *
Ach, was hat er denn?
Der ausgebildete Forstwart
Christopher will Holz zerkleinern.
* Motorsäge stoppt erneut. *
Wenn sie nicht läuft,
musst du von Hand sägen.
Zeig mal her! Warte kurz.
Die Auswanderung
hat die Familie zusammengeschweisst.
Besonders, weil es nicht einfach ist,
in den USA neue Freunde zu finden.
Sie wollen immer zuerst kennenlernen
und erst dann treffen.
Und nicht sich treffen und sich
dann mit der Zeit kennenlernen.
Ich finde die Amerikaner
kompliziert.
Schweiz, Uruguay, USA -
zweimal auswandern
in nur sechs Jahren.
Und trotzdem:
Flurys haben noch nicht genug.
Bei uns kommen die Ideen
immer sehr plötzlich.
Wir sprechen über Chile,
das interessant ist,
oder über den Norden der USA.
Die USA an sich sind derart gross.
Es hat so viele verschiedene
Landschaften, die man besuchen kann.
Aber Christopher und Catherine
wissen auch,
dass es für die Kinder nun wichtig
ist, einmal Wurzeln zu schlagen.
Also vertagen die beiden Abenteurer
ihr Fernweh.
Das Leben geniessen, genau jetzt.
Lieber etwas wagen,
als Träume aufzuschieben.
Dieses Motto zieht sich quer durch
alle zehn Jahre "Auf und davon".
Ich bin unterwegs zu Familie Fischer,
die vor fünf Jahren
bei "Auf und davon" dabei war.
Auch Annette und Kurt
wollten herausfinden,
was das Leben
sonst noch zu bieten hat.
Heute leben sie in Williams Lake.
* Düstere Musik *
Kurz vor dem Städtchen verändert sich
die Landschaft radikal.
Vor einem Jahr
war hier noch alles grün.
Dann wüteten wochenlang
verheerende Waldbrände.
Das Feuer kam dem Haus
der Familie Fischer immer näher -
bis zu dem Punkt, an dem das Feuer
ihre ganze Existenz bedrohte.
Auf den ersten Blick
sieht bei Fischers alles normal aus.
Die Kinder Paul und Kristin
spielen im Garten.
Auch dabei ist
der junge Appenzeller Bläss Gipsy.
Hallo! Wer bist denn du?
Wer bist denn du?
Da kommt die Chefin.
Annette, das freut mich.
Nice to meet you.
- Ja, genau.
Ihr habt es extrem schön hier.
Ich erschrak aber, als wir
durch die abgebrannten Wälder fuhren.
Das ist krass.
- Ja.
Es ging bis zu eurem Dorf, oder?
Ja, es wurde gefährlich.
Ja, wirklich.
Wir mussten evakuieren.
Weil man vor den Bränden Angst hatte?
Ja, es wäre auch fast dazu gekommen.
Wir gingen dann weg.
Hinter dem Haus ...
Hier fiel Asche vom Himmel,
die noch glühte.
Man sah nicht, wie weit
das Feuer wirklich noch weg war.
Wir gingen und dachten,
wir sähen das Haus nie wieder.
Dieses Erlebnis
hat Familie Fischer tief geprägt.
Okay.
Mona, du kannst hier
an unsere super Bar sitzen.
Die Wähe ist für das Abendessen.
Jetzt kommt auch Kurt
von der Arbeit nach Hause.
So ist es einfach.
- Hallo.
Hallo!
Ich habe es auch noch geschafft.
Wir haben einen Spezialgast.
Wir haben es auch schon geschafft.
- Du musst mich zuerst küssen.
Mona. Das freut mich sehr.
- Hallo, Mona. Kurt.
Ihr hattet ein Wahnsinnsjahr.
- Ja, es lief viel.
In den letzten fünf Jahren
lief sehr viel.
So ist das Leben.
- Ja.
Habt ihr euch das mit dem Auswandern
etwas weniger hart vorgestellt,
als es dann war?
Mit dem Brand
hatte ich überhaupt nicht ...
Keine Ahnung!
In der Schweiz wird jeder Brand
einfach sofort gelöscht, nicht?
Das gibt's ja nicht.
Die Feuerwehr kommt innert
fünf Minuten und löscht das Feuer.
Der Brand war wirklich heftig.
- Ja.
Man merkt halt, wie hilflos man ist.
Man kann nur zuschauen
und muss anfangen zu beten.
* Düstere Musik *
Juli 2017:
Waldbrände
breiten sich in Westkanada aus.
Wegen der Trockenheit braucht es nur
einen Funken für ein weiteres Feuer.
Nach Gewittern mit Blitzschlägen
brechen rund um Williams Lake
an vielen Stellen gleichzeitig
Brände aus
und kommen immer näher
an das Haus der Fischers -
an das Haus, in das sie
so viel Herzblut gesteckt haben.
Wir schauen zurück.
November 2013:
Familie Fischer
zieht in ihr neues Zuhause ein.
Muss ich dich
über die Schwelle tragen?
* Lachen *
Freude bei den Kindern
Paul und Kristin.
Lange haben Fischers
nach diesem Haus gesucht.
Rund 350'000 Fr. hat es gekostet.
Läuft die Heizung?
- Ja.
Milchkanne. Frosch.
Achtung, die Brio-Bahn.
Willst du wirklich hier schlafen?
- Ja.
Leute, wir sind wieder zu Hause.
Hier haben Fischers mehr Platz
als noch in Staufen/AG.
In der Schweiz führten sie
eigentlich ein gutes Leben.
Abgesehen davon,
dass Kurt als Selbstständiger
zu viel Zeit
in seiner Schreinerei verbrachte.
Und da war noch dieser Wunsch
auszuwandern bei Kurt -
seit seinem Kanada-Aufenthalt
in jungen Jahren.
Irgendwann
sagte Annette schliesslich Ja.
Das ist nicht normal!
* Sie schreit. *
Hopp!
Kurt ist ausgebildeter Zimmermann.
Hier in Kanada hat er nun einen Job
in der Königsdisziplin
der Ingenieurskunst mit Holz:
im Blockhausbau.
Es ist schon schön,
hier ein Haus aufzustellen.
Für Kurt  d e r  Traumberuf.
Alle Häuser werden auf dem Firmensitz
zuerst konstruiert und aufgebaut,
dann wieder
komplett auseinandergenommen
und am endgültigen Standort
wieder zusammengesetzt.
In dieser Zeit ist Kurt dann bis
zu zwei Wochen lang weg von zu Hause.
Eine anstrengende Arbeit -
besonders für den Rücken.
Eine Spezialität
von Kurts Arbeitgeber:
Holzskulpturen aller Art,
die fix am Blockhaus montiert werden.
Let him down!
Wenn Kurt
nicht gerade auf Montage ist,
verbringt die Familie nun mehr Zeit
miteinander als noch in der Schweiz.
Jetzt machen wir hier in Kanada
doch dasselbe wie in der Schweiz.
Cervelat bräteln in Kanada.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Das ist jetzt eben diese Mischung,
die es ausmacht.
(Kristin) In der Schweiz habe ich
auch schwarze Würste gegessen.
Fischers führen ein zufriedenes Leben
- mit kleinen Schwierigkeiten.
Paul fährt zum allerersten Mal
alleine mit dem Schulbus zur Schule.
Gib mir einen Kuss! Tschüss!
* Lachen *
Annette fährt mit dem Auto nach.
Nur um sicherzugehen.
Als sie bei der Schule ankommt,
keine Spur von Paul.
Sie fragt bei der Lehrerin nach.
Haben Sie Paul gesehen?
- Nein, ich weiss nicht, wo er ist.
Vielleicht
ist er im Schulbus geblieben.
Ist er hier nie reingekommen?
Nein. Am besten gehen Sie
zu Rektor Williams.
Wo ist Herr Williams?
Normalerweise bei den Schulbussen.
Annette wird nun richtig nervös.
Paul kann kaum ein Wort Englisch.
Ist er womöglich falsch ausgestiegen?
Oder gar nicht?
Good morning!
- Good morning!
Haben Sie vielleicht Paul gesehen?
Nein.
Er sollte eigentlich hier sein.
Vielleicht
ist er im Schulbus geblieben.
Im Bus geblieben?
Ich weiss nicht,
jedenfalls ist er nicht hier!
Okay, lass uns
die Busfahrerin anrufen! Das war ...
Tracy oder Stacy?
Hallo,
ich suche einen Erstklässler,
der vielleicht im Bus geblieben ist.
Kannst du mal nachschauen?
Er heisst Paul.
Er ist ein neuer Schüler.
Ist er dort?
Okay.
Thank you. Bye!
Er ist im Busdepot.
Er liebt es eben,
mit dem Schulbus zu fahren.
Okay, okay!
Annette fährt ins Busdepot,
um Päuli abzuholen.
Good morning!
- Good morning!
Er ist okay.
Er ist nur sehr traurig.
Wolltest du
noch etwas länger Schulbus fahren?
Die Busfahrerin hat ihn
hinter dem Sitz nicht gesehen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es ist alles gut.
Im Bus kann dir nichts passieren.
* Sanfte Musik *
Penguin!
- Juhu!
Penguin! I'm a penguin!
Achtung!
* Lachen *
Familie Fischer
schien ihr Glück gefunden zu haben -
bis die Waldbrände kamen,
getrieben vom Wind,
immer näher ans Haus heran.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
An dem Abend,
an dem wir gehen mussten,
hatte ich abgeschlossen
mit dem Ganzen hier.
Als ich diese Feuerwand
auf uns zukommen sah,
dieser Rauch und diese Flammen,
dachte ich,
es würde nichts mehr stehen bleiben.
Das war ein schwieriger Moment.
Das kannst du nicht vergessen.
Es schüttelt mich immer wieder,
wenn ich diese Bilder sehe.
Das macht schon Angst.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Ich packte
einfach mal alles zusammen,
von dem ich dachte,
man dürfe es nicht verlieren.
Was nimmt man da mit?
Pässe, Bargeld,
Dokumente der Versicherung.
Die wichtigsten Papiere.
Unsere Ausbildungsdiplome.
Und meine Handorgel.
Die Handorgel?
- Ja.
Wir gingen noch durchs Haus.
Die Autos waren bereit zur Abfahrt.
Man schaut umher.
Es ist ein sehr komisches Gefühl,
wenn du die Dinge anschaust
und eigentlich alles normal ist.
Du überlegst, ob du diese Uhr,
die Kurt in der Schule gemacht hat,
auch noch mitnehmen sollst.
Dann siehst du diese Lampe,
die er auch gemacht hat
und denkst: "Warum nehme ich
das mit, das aber nicht?"
Am Schluss standen wir hier,
schauten uns an und sagten:
"Jetzt müssen wir gehen."
- "Jetzt müssen wir einfach gehen."
Ich habe noch Bündnerfleisch geholt.
Das selbst gemachte?
- Ja, das war mir wichtig.
Genau.
Die Familie fährt
zu einem zentralen Punkt im Dorf,
wo sie auf andere Flüchtende trifft.
Hattest du Panik? Hattest du Angst?
Hier noch nicht,
aber bei der Tankstelle.
Die Luft wurde ja sehr schlecht.
Du musst dir vorstellen ...
So kann man es passend beschreiben:
Es ist, wie wenn du tauchen gehst
und nicht mehr hochkommst.
Es ist,
wie wenn du unter das Eis gerätst
und keine Luft mehr holen kannst.
- Okay.
Die Luft wird plötzlich so schlimm,
dass es beim Atmen schmerzt.
Aber du bist hier
und kannst ja nirgends hin!
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Hier sind sie am Beten.
Wirklich? Seid ihr am Beten?
- Ja.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Ich sagte zu Kurt,
dass ich jetzt gehen wolle.
Genau.
- Ich wollte nicht mehr warten.
Als wir gingen ...
Als wir die Nacht
am See verbrachten,
an diesem geschützten Ort,
habe ich kein Auge zugetan.
Da fängt man an, nachzudenken.
Was ist, wenn hier nichts mehr ist,
wenn alles abbrennt?
Eben: Was machst du dann?
Da habe ich mir überlegt ...
- Was wäre gewesen?
Wir sprachen davon,
in die Schweiz zu gehen.
Wir sagten, dass wir wohl
zurück in die Schweiz müssten.
Familie Fischer findet Unterschlupf
bei Freunden auf einer Farm.
Heute ist ein etwas gefährlicher Tag
mit viel Wind und Gewittern.
Der Wind ist entscheidend.
Dreht er,
ist Fischers Haus akut bedroht.
Löschflugzeuge fliegen pausenlos.
Es dauert drei Wochen, bis die Feuer
endlich unter Kontrolle sind.
Drei Wochen zittern,
bis Familie Fischer
wieder zurück in ihr Zuhause kann.
* Sanfte Musik *
Hat man Angst, dass das
jederzeit wieder passieren könnte?
Wenn es wieder so ...
- Bei Gewitter sind wir nervös.
Nervöser als vorher.
- Ja.
Wenn ein Flugzeug
über unser Haus fliegt ...
Diese Wasserflugzeuge.
... rennen wir nach draussen
und schauen, ob etwas los ist.
Hinten steht eine Kiste
mit unseren Sachen.
Ja, ja.
- Die ist parat.
Das haben wir gelernt.
Die wichtigsten Dokumente sind dort.
Das haben wir im Sommer
wieder gemacht.
Im Winter
ist es ein bisschen relaxter.
Das lehrt einen, das Leben
dann zu geniessen, wenn man es kann.
* Entspannte Musik *
Und das machen Fischers.
Jeder von ihnen geniesst das Leben
hier in Williams Lake auf seine Art.
* Entspannte Musik *
Bei Fischers
schreit am Morgen nicht der Hahn ...
* Brüllen *
... sondern das Hochlandrind.
Tschüss! Mach's gut in der Schule!
Morgenroutine.
Was Fischers früher
selbstverständlich abspulten,
schätzen sie heute viel mehr -
nicht nur wegen dem grossen Feuer.
Nein, Fischers mussten
eine zweite harte Probe überstehen:
Kurt war wochenlang arbeitsunfähig
und musste seinen Traumjob aufgeben.
Er fährt los
zu seinem neuen Arbeitsort.
Und Annette geht in den Garten,
wie jeden Morgen.
Sie, die ausgebildete Gärtnerin
und ehemalige Lehrerin
an einer Landwirtschaftsschule,
setzt ihr Wissen heute praktisch ein.
In der Schweiz
hatte ich einen kleinen Garten.
Das war mein Ausgleich zur Schule.
Hier habe ich ja sonst keinen Job.
Der Garten ist eigentlich mein Job.
Das, was ich hier produzieren kann,
müssen wir nicht kaufen.
Das ist eigentlich mein Lohn.
Der Lohn aus dem Garten
war besonders wichtig in der Zeit,
als Kurt nicht mehr arbeiten konnte.
Das ist Kurts neuer Arbeitsort:
ein kleines Holzhaus.
Aus dem Blockhausbauer
ist ein Bürogummi geworden,
der Pläne am Computer zeichnet.
Und doch ist Kurt
jetzt happy mit der Situation.
Wenigstens hat er
keine Rückenschmerzen mehr.
Die harte Arbeit auf der Baustelle
war Gift für seine Bandscheiben.
Am Schluss hatte ich
ein taubes Gefühl im ganzen Bein.
Da sagte der Arzt,
dass es so nicht weitergehen könne.
Ich auch. Ich musste ziemlich lange
liegen und Schmerzmittel nehmen.
Starke Schmerzmittel.
Der Schmerz ging nicht mehr weg.
Da war klar,
dass es nur mit Operieren geht.
Zuerst lag er
einen Sommer lang auf dem Sofa.
Wenn er ging, ging er so:
Wie ein 80-Jähriger.
Danach ...
Er ging zum Arzt
und machte Akupunktur.
Es ging darum,
ob er operieren solle oder nicht.
Wir wollten eigentlich
keine Operation.
Aber da es nicht besser wurde,
wurde das unausweichlich.
Nach der Operation hatte ich
sozusagen keine Schmerzen mehr.
Aber der Arzt sagte,
wenn ich ihn nicht mehr sehen wolle,
müsse ich den Job wechseln.
Für mich war es schlimm,
nicht zu wissen,
wo wir in einem Jahr sind ...
... oder wie wir weitermachen.
Wie verdienen wir unser Geld?
Das Schicksal
meinte es gut mit ihnen:
Kurt erhielt bei einem ausgewanderten
Schweizer Bauunternehmer die Chance,
sich neu zu orientieren.
Seither
konstruiert er Pläne am Computer.
Es ist natürlich nicht dasselbe,
wie selber Häuser aufzustellen.
Auf der Heimfahrt
zieht Kurts alter Arbeitsort vorbei.
Manchmal
schaue ich schon mit Wehmut hin
und denke, dass ich jetzt dort sein
und dort arbeiten sollte.
Jetzt ist es halt nicht mehr so.
Die Arbeit dort
war schon sehr interessant.
Es schmerzt, wenn ich zurückdenke,
was eigentlich sein könnte
und was ich jetzt nicht mehr habe.
Aber so ist es nun mal.
Das Leben geht weiter.
Jetzt müssen wir vorwärtsschauen
und das Beste daraus machen.
* Gänseschnattern *
Das sind Gänse.
Schau, sie fliegen in den Süden!
Vorwärtsschauen - darin
ist Familie Fischer jetzt geübt.
Zweimal
stand ihre Existenz auf dem Spiel:
durch den Verlust der Arbeit
und durch die riesigen Waldbrände.
Zweimal rappelten sie sich auf
und machten weiter.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ganz ohne körperliche Arbeit
geht es bei Kurt dann doch nicht.
In seiner neuen, sehr geräumigen
Werkstatt, die er selber gebaut hat -
oder besser: selber bauen wollte.
Alles war vorbereitet,
um Aufzurichten,
aber dann streikte sein Rücken.
Spontan kamen Kurts Blockhausbauer-
freunde, um ihm zu helfen.
Sie bauten die Werkstatt
in zwei Tagen auf.
Ist das dein Reich?
- Ja, das ist mein kleines Reich.
Wozu habt ihr das?
Damit Kurt
nicht im Haushalt helfen muss?
Genau, das ist mein Spielplatz hier.
Ob sie die Werkstatt professionell
nutzen wollen, ist noch nicht klar.
Aber für den Raum oben im Schopf
haben sie konkrete Pläne:
Hier wollen sie
ein Bed & Breakfast einrichten.
Das wäre das hier.
Wie müssen wir uns das vorstellen,
sollte es ein Bed & Breakfast geben?
Du bist eben zur Tür reingekommen.
- Ich bin hier reingekommen.
Eine kleine Terrasse mit einer Tür.
Grosse Fenster,
damit Licht hereinkommt.
Ja, grosse Fenster.
Hier wäre wieder eine Wand.
Eine Hollywoodschaukel
wäre auch noch cool.
Hier?
- Ja.
Die Aussicht ist wunderschön. Super!
Ich glaube,
ihr müsst selber hier einziehen!
Die Erste, die hier Ferien macht,
bin ich. Das ist kein Witz!
Das bist du.
- Das bin ich. Wenn es fertig ist.
Ich komme mit.
Dann sitzen wir
auf unserem neuen Balkon ...
... und schauen unseren Kühen zu,
wie sie sich vergnügen.
Ich muss noch den Kühen rufen.
* Kurt pfeift. *
Kennen sie deinen Lockruf?
- Ja, die kennen mich.
* Kurt pfeift. *
Hast du gesehen?
Sie hat ein abgebrochenes Horn.
Wer?
- Gini.
Wirklich? Wollen wir es
uns anschauen? Komm mit!
* Bellen *
Hey, hör jetzt auf! No!
- Gipsy, no, no, no, no!
Uh!
- The horn!
Oh!
Was ist mit dem Horn passiert?
Hattest du einen Fight, Gini?
Kurt - aufgewachsen auf einem
Bauernhof - kümmert sich um das Tier.
Er desinfiziert die Wunde.
Ja, ja, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Wenn das Horn abfällt,
müssen wir sie schlachten.
I say.
- Ja, ja.
Bist du der Chef hier?
Ja, von diesem Kalb schon.
- Von diesem Kalb? Vom schwarzen?
Vom schwarz-weissen.
Ja, das gehört ihm.
Deshalb sagst du,
wann es geschlachtet wird?
Ja.
- Und wann wird es geschlachtet?
(Kristin) When he dies.
- Vielleicht im Januar.
- Januar ist okay. Abgemacht?
Vielleicht. Ich muss noch überlegen.
Er möchte, dass es
noch ein bisschen grösser wird.
Die Hälfte des Erlöses geht an ihn,
weil es sein Kalb war.
Aha!
Ah, du erhältst
die Hälfte des Geldes? Wow!
Gipsy!
Hey, fertig! No!
Du, sonst nehmen wir dich!
Meinst du? Wenn sie es gelernt hat.
Jetzt bist du oben.
Du wolltest hinauf.
Fischers
haben verrückte Jahre hinter sich.
Annette sagte mir, dass sie, hätten
sie alles gewusst, was sie erwartet,
vielleicht nicht ausgewandert wären.
Auch diesen Satz haben wir in zehn
Jahren "Auf und davon" oft gehört.
Und trotzdem sagen am Schluss alle,
sie seien froh, es gemacht zu haben.
Meine Reise geht
ein paar Hundert Kilometer weiter
zu unserer
nächsten Auswandererfamilie.
Und an dieser Stelle
schauen wir noch einmal
über den kanadischen Horizont hinaus.
Zeit für eine
ganz neue Auswanderergeschichte -
ausgewählt aus den vielen
"Auf und davon"-Bewerbungen,
die wir bis jetzt
noch nicht erzählen konnten.
In diesen zehn Jahren
"Auf und davon"
haben wir ganz viele Familien
und Paare begleitet -
nicht nur nach Kanada.
Wenn man ein solches Projekt
gemeinsam anpackt,
braucht es richtig viel Mut.
Aber wenn man es alleine macht
und auch noch an einen Ort geht,
wo man als weisse Frau
die absolute Exotin ist,
dann braucht es
noch ein bisschen mehr.
Im Süden des Senegals,
in der Stadt Sedhiou.
Hierhin verschlägt es keine Touristen
und es gibt
kein internationales Business.
Der einzige Mensch weisser Hautfarbe
ist hier
die Schweizerin Marielle Furter.
Fliessend Wasser und Strom gibt es
in dieser Region noch fast nicht.
So holt die 54-jährige Marielle
ihr Wasser jeden Tag
frisch am Quartierbrunnen.
Erst kürzlich
ist sie in ein neues Haus gezogen.
Vorher lebte sie noch viel einfacher,
mit 15 Erwachsenen und ebenso
vielen Kindern in zwei Häusern.
Es ist nicht unbedingt bequem und
komfortabel, aber mir gefällt das.
Ich mag es ganz einfach.
Kennengelernt haben wir
Marielle Furter vor fünf Jahren.
Wir besuchten sie damals für
ein Casting in Meisterschwanden/AG.
Das ist schon etwas von dem,
was mir am meisten schwerfällt
und was ich am meisten vermisse.
Sicher auch Freunde und Familie,
aber es ist nicht einfach,
meine Katzen loszulassen.
Ich kam in Dakar an,
nahm das Schiff in den Süden
und landete in Ziguinchor.
Etwas in mir drin sagte:
"Hier ist es!"
Ich wurde herzlich aufgenommen
und hatte ganz schöne Kontakte.
Irgendwie hatte ich das Gefühl,
dass hier das sein könnte,
was schon lange in mir schlummert,
nämlich der Gedanke,
irgendwo Kinder in Sachen Bildung
zu unterstützen.
Etwas tun bei Leuten,
denen es nicht so gut geht wie uns.
Wenn ich zurückkam und gleich
wieder die nächsten Ferien buchte,
hiess es jeweils:
"Und, hast du dich verliebt?"
"Ich habe einen Dokumentarfilm
gesehen" und "Ich habe gehört" usw.
Natürlich auch,
weil ich alleine lebe.
Es ist tatsächlich so,
dass ich mich verliebt habe,
aber in Afrika, in die Leute
und in den Senegal.
* Rhythmische, afrikanische Musik *
Nun wohnt Marielle im Senegal,
in Sedhiou.
Mittlerweile hat sie auch
einen Partner, den 46-jährigen Elash.
Statt um Katzen kümmert sich Marielle
nun um die Hunde ihres Partners.
Vor vier Jahren ist Marielle
in den Senegal ausgewandert.
Es waren
sehr kräfteraubende Jahre für sie -
trotz der grossen Unterstützung
von Elash.
Nun stehen die stressigsten Tage
ihrer ganzen Auswanderung bevor.
1964 in Muri zur Welt gekommen,
wuchs Marielle
als jüngstes von vier Kindern auf.
Nach einer Ausbildung als Malerin
fand sie ihre Berufung schliesslich
als Kindergartenlehrerin.
Obwohl sie selbst
gerne Kinder gehabt hätte,
hatte das Leben anderes mit ihr vor.
Sie wanderte schon einmal aus
und lebte sechs Jahre
in Mittelamerika.
Zurück in der Schweiz arbeitete sie
wieder als Kindergärtnerin.
Doch da war die Suche
nach mehr Sinn in ihrem Leben.
Bonjour les enfants!
Also setzt sie das Projekt um,
das schon länger in ihr schlummerte:
Sie gründet den gemeinnützigen Verein
kindergardens4senegal.
Mit Spenden, Lehrgeld und Herzblut
baut Marielle
einen ersten Kindergarten
in einer abgelegenen Region
des Landes.
Ich kann in diesen Kindergarten
gehen, wann ich will:
Die Kinder sind dort,
die Lehrerinnen sind dort.
Die Kinder entwickeln sich.
Ich kann also sagen: Ziel erreicht!
Das gab mir den Mut, einen zweiten
Kindergarten in Angriff zu nehmen.
Marielle
stürzt sich wieder in die Arbeit.
Zwei Jahre ist die Kindergärtnerin
nun Bauleiterin,
organisiert von 7 Uhr bis 23 Uhr.
Oft ist sie erschöpft.
Doch nun
steht das von ihr entworfene Gebäude.
Sie bringt Spielsachen
zum Kindergarten.
Alles Spenden aus der Schweiz.
Ca va? C'est bien comme ca?
- Oui, oui.
Rund um das Haus
wird noch fleissig gearbeitet.
Auch Partner Elash packt mit an.
Morgen ist bereits die Eröffnung.
Die WC-Schüsseln
werden noch eingebaut.
Für den Wasseranschluss
reicht es aber nicht mehr.
Immer wieder gibt es Überraschungen.
Man muss jeden Tag nehmen,
wie er kommt.
Nur nichts planen, nichts erwarten.
Einfach kommen und schauen.
Heute könnte man z.B.
die Türen einbauen.
Vielleicht kommen die Türen,
vielleicht nicht.
Vielleicht passen sie,
Man muss jeden Tag, jede Stunde,
jede Minute nehmen, wie sie kommen.
Das lehrt einen Afrika.
Jetzt, wo der Kindergarten gebaut ist
und Marielles Energiereserven
schon fast erschöpft sind,
steht noch ein letzter Kraftakt an:
das Eröffnungsfest - ein wichtiger
Anlass für die Menschen hier.
Klappt das mit dem Gebäck?
- Es braucht Reis morgen!
Es braucht unbedingt Reis!
Jetzt wollen sie
noch ein Reisessen organisieren,
weil das ganze Volk zusammenkomme,
wie unser Chauffeur sagt.
Er hat es
noch nicht ganz verstanden.
Wenn ich es finanziere,
organisiert er es.
Es wird so sein:
Das ganze Dorf kommt zusammen.
Ein grosses Fest.
Ich wollte eine kleine Feier
am ersten Tag,
an dem die Kinder kommen.
Aber eher mit Snacks.
Sie sind jetzt dran.
Aber sie wollen nun Reis.
Ohne Reis geht gar nichts in Afrika.
Merci beaucoup.
Ca va?
Tu vas bien?
Uh, je suis tres contente. Vraiment.
In den Spendenkartons aus der Schweiz
findet Marielle einen kleinen
Erinnerungsfetzen an die alte Heimat.
# Ta-ta!
Ich dachte,
ich könnte das symbolisch aufhängen.
Aber wenn sie
eine grosse Senegalfahne bringen,
ist es mickerig, eine so kleine
Schweizerfahne aufzuhängen.
Schliesslich verdanken wir
den Kindergarten der Schweiz.
# Trittst im Morgenrot daher ...
Marielle hat deshalb beim Schneider
extra eine grössere Schweizerfahne
in Auftrag gegeben.
C'est l'hymne suisse.
Die letzten Vorbereitungen
für das Eröffnungsfest laufen.
Einmal mehr nicht alles wie geplant.
Sonst lassen wir das mit den Stühlen
und allem.
Dafür haben wir schlicht keine Zeit.
Die Stühle kommen einfach nicht.
Und die Segeltücher kommen nicht.
Alles, was der Gemeinderat
übernehmen wollte.
Sie bezahlen es,
aber organisieren müssen wir es.
On fait une, deux, trois.
- Oui, une, deux, trois.
On attache une, on attache l'autre,
on attache trois.
Die Schweizerfahne wird geliefert.
Marielle hat genau skizziert,
wie sie auszusehen hat.
Die Abstände stimmen nicht,
aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Ich glaube, wir lassen es.
Man kann es
als Schweizerfahne erkennen.
Schon okay.
Das ist nicht mein grösstes Problem.
Sie hetzt weiter zu den Köchinnen.
Ah, ich bin jetzt schon k.o.,
das muss ich sagen.
Bonjour!
Uh, on est deja en preparation.
Es fehlen noch einige Zutaten.
Marielle verspricht,
diese noch heute Abend zu besorgen.
* Sanfter, afrikanischer Gesang *
Ah, es ist unglaublich!
Marielle möchte einkaufen.
Ein Plattfuss.
Das kommt hier täglich vor.
Wir überlegen,
ob wir es heute reparieren lassen.
Die andere Variante ist pumpen
und schauen, wie weit wir kommen.
Das ist sehr afrikanisch.
Ich bin für morgen.
* Sie seufzt. *
Oui, c'est ca.
Weiter geht's
auf die afrikanische Art.
Okay, bonne soiree!
* Afrikanische Trommelmusik *
* Hupen *
Noch ist genug Luft im Schlauch.
Wie immer
fällt Marielle als weisse Frau auf.
Sie muss aufpassen,
dass sie als Westlerin
nicht zu viel bezahlt beim Einkauf.
Was kannst du mir
für einen Preis machen?
Der Preis ist schon der richtige.
Sie verhandeln den Preis
noch ein bisschen nach unten,
weil ich so viel gekauft habe.
Von 35'700 auf 35'000
runtergehandelt.
Das ist rund 1 Fr.
Merci beaucoup.
Er ist ein Zäher.
Ein anderer wäre eher runter
oder hätte uns etwas geschenkt.
* Sie unterhalten sich
in afrikanischer Sprache. *
Schon wieder am Pumpen.
Das ist nun
die afrikanische Variante.
Man fährt ein Stück
und pumpt wieder.
Marielle möchte schleunigst ins Bett,
damit sie morgen für den grossen
Eröffnungstag genügend Energie hat.
* Titelmelodie von "Auf und davon" *
Zwei Jahre aufopfernde Arbeit.
Heute endlich
ist die Einweihung des Kindergartens.
Auch die Stühle
sind noch eingetroffen.
Noch ein bisschen Ruhe
vor dem Sturm.
Wir wollten eigentlich
um 8 Uhr beginnen,
damit es dann so gegen 10 Uhr
losgehen kann.
Das gehört hier einfach dazu.
So habe ich auch noch etwas Zeit
für die letzten Handgriffe.
Es kommt tatsächlich das ganze Dorf.
* Trommeln *
* Trommeln und Trillerpfeife *
Auch ein politischer Würdenträger
taucht auf.
Der Präfekt von Sedhiou,
der zweithöchste Regierungsbeamte
der Region.
Marielle hatte mit ihm
noch nie etwas zu tun.
Erschöpfung oder die Aufregung?
Die Nerven liegen blank bei Marielle.
Möchten Sie auch etwas sagen
zur Eröffnung?
Ja, klar.
Ich arbeite zwei Jahre lang
für diesen Kindergarten
und dann
soll ich keine Ansprache halten?
Natürlich dürfen Sie reden.
Möchten Sie beide etwas sagen?
Ah, ja! Elash soll auch etwas sagen.
Er ist mein gleichwertiger Partner.
Bonjour monsieur!
Vous allez bien?
- C'est le president du departement.
Wir begrüssen die Repräsentantin
unserer Schweizer Partner.
Wie die Schweizer Repräsentantin
heisst,
ist wohl irgendwo in den Akten
untergegangen.
Unsere Schweizer Partnerin ...
... Marielle.
- Marielle, voila.
Sie wird nun zu uns sprechen.
* Applaus *
Wir sind heute hier
für die Eröffnung des Kindergartens.
Zwei Jahre
haben wir dafür gearbeitet.
Und jetzt ist alles bereit.
Ich bin glücklich,
dass die Kinder nun
zum ersten Mal in die Zimmer können.
Merci beaucoup. Abaraka.
* Applaus *
Nach dem feierlichen Zerschneiden
des Eröffnungsbandes folgt das Essen.
Elash, tu viens aussi?
Mit dem Reis hat es irgendwie
doch nicht geklappt.
Jetzt bin ich wirklich happy.
Die Schule ist eingeweiht.
Man hat sie gesegnet.
Es fielen schöne,
wertschätzende Worte.
Die Kinder sind aufgeregt.
Sie dürfen bald reinschauen.
Doch, ich bin zufrieden.
Was Marielle nicht weiss:
Während sie isst, werden die Kinder
entgegen allen Abmachungen
bereits in ihre Klassenzimmer geführt
und danach nach Hause geschickt.
* Trommeln *
Als Marielle davon erfährt,
ist die Enttäuschung,
aber auch der Ärger gross.
Die machen, was sie wollen!
Sie haben das ganze Fest abgeändert.
Ich war nicht einmal dabei,
als die Kinder zum ersten Mal
in den Kindergarten durften.
Das ist für mich
der grösste Moment des Ganzen.
Das haben sie jetzt
einfach dazwischen gemacht.
Das schmerzt schon ein bisschen.
* Trommeln *
Die Einheimischen feiern weiter.
Sie wissen nicht um Marielles Frust.
Für Marielle
ist das Fest jedoch gelaufen.
Manchmal fühle ich mich auch einsam.
Hilflos, ausgeliefert.
Ich alleine hier.
Kein Mensch, der mich versteht.
Hier bin ich in der Pampa.
Hier gibt es keine Attraktion,
also kommt auch niemand.
Dann bist du in der Pampa,
mit deinen Kindergartenprojekten,
die hier Sinn machen und nicht
in den touristischen Orten.
Dort unterstützen andere.
Dann merkst du plötzlich,
dass es hier keinen Menschen
mit deiner Hautfarbe und mit deiner
Denkweise gibt, der mich versteht,
mit dem ich einen Kaffee trinken
und meinen Frust ablassen
oder meine übersprudelnde Freude
mitteilen kann.
Ich kann es vielleicht per WhatsApp
machen, mit einer Sprachnachricht.
Und das ist manchmal hart.
* Fröhlicher Gesang
aus dem Kindergarten *
Am Tag nach der Eröffnung
kehrt Marielle
nochmals zurück zum Kindergarten.
Er ist schon in vollem Betrieb.
Für die Kinder hat sie
die viele Arbeit auf sich genommen.
Die Kleinen jetzt fröhlich zu sehen,
ist Balsam für ihre Seele.
Ich bin sehr erschöpft.
Und nachdem gestern alles
so anders lief, als ich dachte,
kam wieder alles hoch, die ganze
Mühe und Not mit diesen Leuten.
Aber jetzt muss ich sagen,
wenn es jetzt so anläuft ...
Ja.
Es könnte sein,
dass ich plötzlich sage: "Komm!"
Wenn es zwei, drei Jahre
super läuft mit diesen Kindern ...
Ich habe sie halt schon sehr lieb.
Man baut ja in dieser Zeit
auch eine Beziehung auf. Wer weiss?
Gestern dachte ich: "Nie wieder!"
Heute schwappt es aber schon wieder.
* Afrikanische Musik und Gesang *
Aber erst einmal
will Marielle Furter sich erholen ...
... und das Leben im Senegal
geniessen.
Und das ist nur möglich
ohne ein Projekt.
Zehn Jahre "Auf und davon".
Wir sind zurück in Kanada
und unterwegs zu meiner
nächsten Station: Clearwater.
Die kanadische Mentalität
ist uns Schweizern sicher näher
als diejenige
auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent.
Aber auch hier
kann es Probleme geben,
wenn man z.B.
in die Mühlen der Bürokratie gerät,
wie Familie Volk, die wir vor zwei
Jahren in unserer Sendung hatten.
Sie erinnern sich bestimmt.
Sie haben ein grosses Thema,
das sie beschäftigt:
dass sie nämlich
noch immer nicht wissen,
ob sie in Kanada bleiben dürfen.
Verdammt!
Du hurenelende, hurenverdammte Sau!
Geh doch jetzt einfach in dieses
verdammte, verreckte Mauseloch!
Es ist nicht zu glauben! Es nervt!
Die Volks mussten sich oft nerven
während ihrer Auswanderung.
Schon als sie noch in einem Blockhaus
in der Schweiz lebten.
Im zürcherischen Benken
beginnt ihr langer Kampf
mit den kanadischen Behörden
um ein Visum.
Völlig überraschend wird ihr Antrag
für eine Aufenthaltsbewilligung
im Sommer 2015 abgelehnt.
Simone Volk ist konsterniert.
Geht jetzt alles
irgendwie in die Hose?
Wir erfüllen alles, was sie wollen.
Wir bringen ihnen Kapital.
Wir haben eine Firma.
Wir schaffen viele Arbeitsplätze.
Wir haben eine innovative Technik,
die sie dort gar nicht kennen,
aber unbedingt brauchen.
Wir haben Verträge.
Wir wissen einfach nicht,
was nicht passt.
Das versteht niemand.
Damit haben wir nicht gerechnet.
Das Haus ist verkauft, ja mehr noch,
schon fast komplett geräumt.
Als Zwischenlösung
bis zur Auswanderung
wohnt die Familie bei Simones Eltern.
Es ist unsere ganze Existenz.
Wir haben Maschinen gekauft
nur für das. Das sind ...
Ich darf
gar nicht darüber nachdenken.
Wenn das nicht klappt,
weiss ich auch nicht.
Volks wollen in Kanada Forstwirt-
schaft im steilen Gelände betreiben.
Auch die teuren Spezialmaschinen
haben sie bereits verschifft.
Das ist jetzt ganz neu.
Du musst hier unterschreiben.
Aufgeben ist keine Option.
Wir stellen den Antrag noch einmal.
Diesmal in Papierform.
(Gion) Können wir nicht auswandern?
- Ja, wir dürfen nicht auswandern.
Sie haben es uns abgelehnt.
Jetzt müssen wir alles
nochmals in Papierform schicken.
Unser Auswanderungsberater meint,
dass es so vielleicht
doch noch akzeptiert wird.
Prinzip Hoffnung
bei Simone und Christian Volk.
Der sechsjährige Sohn Gion
nimmt das alles unbeschwerter.
Unser Herr Busi hat geschrieben.
- Der Berater?
"The online status
of your applications has changed."
"Refused is replaced by submitted.
Looks good."
Das glaubst du nicht, oder?
Beim letzten Mal
war es "geschlossen" und "refused".
Und jetzt ist es wieder ...
"Refused" ist nicht mehr drin.
Es ist einfach "in Bearbeitung".
Überraschend schnell erhält
die Familie doch noch ein Visum.
Die Volks ziehen um
in ein riesiges kanadisches Landhaus.
Weshalb der Antrag zuerst abgelehnt
wurde und dann doch bewilligt,
weiss die Familie nicht.
Die Entscheide der kanadischen
Bürokratie sind unergründlich.
Das werden die Volks
noch zur Genüge zu spüren bekommen,
denn bis jetzt haben sie
erst ein temporäres Arbeitsvisum.
Christian
nimmt die Arbeit im Wald auf.
Seine Firma
hat sofort zahlreiche Aufträge.
Simone bemüht sich um die
dauerhafte Aufenthaltsbewilligung,
dem sog. Permanent Resident.
Welche Nummer ist es?
Doch die kanadischen Behörden
lassen nichts von sich hören.
Ach nein! Guck mal, gar nichts!
Christians und Simones Firma boomt.
Sie kaufen neue Maschinen,
stellen kanadisches Personal ein
und bezahlen auch Steuern.
Volks sind die perfekten Einwanderer.
Ah, das ist wieder super!
Sie haben unseren Permanent-
Resident-Antrag abgelehnt.
Einen der beiden.
Hallo?
Welcher denn?
Weil wir selbstständig sind,
oder was?
Okay.
Jetzt noch einer und dann
ist es dann wirklich gelaufen.
"Thank you for your interest
you have shown in Canada."
Dieser Satz ist ein Hohn!
Dieser Satz ist wirklich ein Hohn.
Wenn wir den Permanent Resident
nicht bekommen, bedeutet das,
dass wir das Land nächstes Jahr am
18. August wieder verlassen müssen.
Dann läuft unser Work-Visum aus.
Hello!
- Hallo!
Was läuft?
Du hast es ja gehört, oder?
Herrgott,
ist das ein verdammter Scheissdreck!
Es ist wie ein schlechter Witz.
Ich weiss jetzt auch nicht,
was wir machen sollen.
Am besten
das Haus wieder ausschreiben.
Ja.
* Mona pfeift. *
Verkauft haben Volks ihr Haus
auf jeden Fall noch nicht.
So viel haben sie uns
per E-Mail verraten.
Und es gebe
noch eine grosse Neuigkeit,
die nichts mit der
Aufenthaltsbewilligung zu tun habe.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Bellen *
Schon alarmiert!
Der Hund ist schneller als ich.
Ich bin Mona.
- Mona, freut mich!
Es freut mich sehr.
Schön, dass wir euch gefunden haben!
Hallo, Gion!
- Hallo!
Schön, dich zu sehen! Ich bin Mona.
Und euer Hund.
Er ist ein guter Wachhund.
Ja.
Hallihallo!
- Er macht halt ein bisschen Lärm.
Das ist richtig so.
Und jetzt
will die ganze Schweiz wissen:
Was ist
mit der Aufenthaltsbewilligung?
Aber bevor wir das klären,
gibt es ja noch eine kleine,
grosse andere Überraschung.
- Ja, genau.
Können wir die rasch anschauen?
- Auf jeden Fall. Kommt rein!
Simone! Das freut mich sehr.
Herzliche Gratulation!
- Danke schön!
Jetzt ist sie mal wach.
Das ist selten.
Das neueste Mitglied
der Familie Volk.
Wie heisst sie?
- Wie heisst sie?
Leeza.
- Leeza?
Ja, Leeza.
Und du bist froh und glücklich,
eine Schwester zu haben?
Ja.
Er ist ein super grosser Bruder.
Er könnte sie ständig knuddeln.
Wie alt ist sie?
- Vier Wochen.
Ein ganz frisches Glück.
- Ja
Hey, du!
Es blendet, gell!
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui!
Hoppla!
Die ganze Schweiz möchte ja wissen:
Haben Volks endlich
die Aufenthaltsbewilligung?
Dürfen sie in Kanada bleiben
oder nicht?
Gibt es da Neuigkeiten?
Wir haben sie!
- Nein, ihr habt sie!
Ja, endlich!
- Endlich, ja!
Eigentlich überraschend.
Sicher?
Irgendwann
erhielten wir eine Einladung
für ein persönliches Interview
in Vancouver.
Wir dachten: "Nochmals
ein Interview, nochmals Fragen,
nochmals
irgendwelche Papiere mitbringen."
Dann gingen wir hin und kamen mit
dem Permanent Resident wieder raus.
Wir sassen da,
wie der Ochse am Berg.
Dort ging es nur darum,
uns dieses Papier auszuhändigen.
Wir standen draussen
und verstanden die Welt nicht mehr.
Oh Gott, jetzt ist es so weit!
Jetzt betrachtest du alles
von einer anderen Seite.
Jetzt kannst du machen,
was du willst.
Du weisst, dass es nun durch ist.
Jetzt seid ihr freie Menschen -
auch in Kanada.
Zuvor
standet ihr ständig unter Druck.
Wir hatten so viel gebaut
und investiert.
Im Hinterkopf hatte man immer,
was sein würde,
wenn wir wieder gehen müssten.
Jetzt gehört alles uns.
- Ja, genau.
Wenn ich euch so anschaue,
habe ich nicht das Gefühl,
dass ihr
viele graue Haare bekommen habt.
Die sind blondiert.
* Lachen *
Und bei ihm
ist das Licht gerade günstig.
Zwei Wochen vor Leezas Geburt
haben Volks ihre
Aufenthaltsbewilligung erhalten.
So viel Glück in so kurzer Zeit.
Was ist denn das Schönes?
So ein Dragon.
Die werden so lang und so dick.
- Wow!
Wieso gefallen dir solche Tiere?
Ich mag solche Kriechviecher.
Kriechviecher?
Papa gefallen sie nicht so, oder?
Nein.
Ihn ekelt es,
wenn sie zu nahe kommen.
Aber Mama sagte,
jeder kriege ein Geschenk,
wenn wir den Permanent haben.
Ah, den hast du gekriegt, als ihr
die Aufenthaltsbewilligung hattet?
Das war meine einzige Chance,
ihn zu kriegen.
Und jetzt geht's hinaus.
* Sanfte Bluesklänge *
Wir machen
einen kleinen Familienausflug
zu einem der schönsten Plätze
in der Gegend.
* Sanfte Bluesklänge *
Jetzt, mit der Aufenthaltsbewilligung
in der Tasche
können Volks ihr Leben
unbeschwert geniessen -
wenn sie sich denn dafür Zeit nähmen,
was selten vorkommt.
Christian hat mit seiner
Holzfällerfirma immer viel zu tun.
* Sanfte Bluesklänge *
Das sind die Helmcken Falls.
141 m fällt das Wasser in die Tiefe.
In ihrem alten Leben wohnten Volks
in der Nähe des Rheinfalls,
aber dieser Wasserfall ist
noch einmal eine andere Kategorie.
Was wünscht ihr euch?
Was habt ihr vor?
Ich wünsche mir,
dass die Firma einmal so rund läuft,
dass er auch ein bisschen mehr
zu Hause sein kann.
Damit er
ums Haus herum arbeiten kann.
Nicht,
dass er tagelang hier sein muss,
aber ab und zu den Luxus erleben,
zu Hause zu bleiben
und etwas ums Haus herum zu machen.
Es ist schon besser als am Anfang.
Aber es wäre schön, wenn es
noch ein bisschen mehr wäre, oder?
Okay.
Jetzt kannst du ihn noch fragen.
Ist es realistisch in nächster Zeit?
Im Moment ist es so,
dass ich gerne draussen bin.
Jetzt fahre ich
auch wieder meine eigenen Maschinen.
Was gibt es Schöneres,
als am Morgen rauszufahren?
Am besten an einen Ort,
wo niemand ist.
Da bist du für dich alleine.
So kannst du deine Arbeit machen.
Was gibt es Schöneres?
Ja, das natürlich auch.
Unsere Wünsche
decken sich noch nicht ganz,
aber wir arbeiten daran.
Man muss nicht immer gleicher Meinung
sein, aber am gleichen Strick ziehen,
besonders,
wenn man zusammen auswandert.
Ich bin wieder on the road -
unterwegs zu unserer
letzten Auswandererfamilie.
Ruckstuhls sind die einzigen,
die nichts mit Wald am Hut haben.
Wir sind in Alberta, auf der
anderen Seite der Rocky Mountains.
Diese Gegend
ist geprägt von Landwirtschaft.
Die Hälfte des Fleisches in Kanada
wird hier produziert.
Die regionale Spezialität:
Beef Jerky. Das ist Trockenfleisch
in allen Variationen.
"Dog Jerky"? Ist das für den Hund
oder gemacht aus dem Hund?
Sicherheitshalber
nehme ich ein anderes.
Etwas zu knabbern
für die nächste, ganz neue Geschichte
in der Jubiläumssendung
zehn Jahre "Auf und davon".
Wäre es auch Kanada, wenn sie sich
ein neues Land aussuchen würden?
Oder eher Australien
oder Skandinavien?
Das sind ja auch Sehnsuchtsländer
für uns Schweizer.
Aber es gibt auch Leute,
die wollen an exotische Orte,
die auch wir
auf der Karte suchen müssen.
Als sich Familie Balmer
bei uns bewarb, wussten wir:
Das gibt ein Abenteuer.
Familie Balmer -
das sind Fritz und Brigitte ...
... und Brigittes Kinder
Nathalie, Francine und Johnny.
Die Familie
lebt in Belize in Mittelamerika.
Und das hat sie Fritz,
dem Familienoberhaupt, zu verdanken.
Fritz wuchs auf einem Bauernhof
im Kanton Zürich auf.
Er träumte schon als kleiner Junge
von der grossen, weiten Welt.
Ich hatte von klein auf in meinem
Zimmer Segelschiffe aufgehängt.
Das war für mich immer
ein Symbol für Weite und Freiheit.
Doch Fritz wurde 52 Jahre alt, bis er
endlich die Partnerin gefunden hatte,
die bereit war,
mit ihm zusammen auszuwandern.
Brigitte, Mutter von fünf Kindern.
Die beiden hatten sich 2008 auf einer
Online-Partnerbörse kennengelernt.
Eine späte Liebe
mit weitreichenden Folgen.
Die beiden landen zusammen
auf einem anderen Kontinent.
Grundsätzlich ist nichts so,
wie es geplant war.
In Zweidlen/ZH casten wir 2012
die Patchworkfamilie Balmer.
Du bist die Ältere, oder?
- Nein.
Kurz vor ihrer Abreise nach Belize.
Ich kam von der Arbeit nach Hause
und er sagte zu mir:
"Ich weiss jetzt,
wohin wir auswandern."
Ich habe ein bisschen
auf Google Earth geforscht.
U.a. las ich irgendwo,
dass dort eines
der schönsten Tauchatolle sei.
Ich tauche auch sehr gerne.
Dann habe ich es
über Google Earth näher angeschaut.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
das sei eigentlich eine tolle Sache.
Es sah noch gut aus
und war überschaubar.
Am Anfang hatte ich
schon noch Sicherheitsbedenken.
Es kam ja wirklich
aus dem Bauch heraus.
Ich wollte nicht!
- Ganz am Anfang nicht, oder?
Wir gingen dann als Familie
für zwei Wochen dorthin.
Wir sahen uns alles an -
vom Norden bis in den Süden.
Nach drei Tagen kaufte Fritz - ich
war geschockt - dieses Land hier.
Wir sahen nicht wirklich viel
von diesem Land.
Es war alles überwachsen.
Eigentlich war es ein Bauchgefühl.
Und das ist ja ein grosses Gefühl.
Der Plan: Balmers
wollen eine Bäckerei eröffnen.
Die Maschinen dafür
kaufen sie schon in der Schweiz.
Ihr ganzes Hab und Gut
packen sie in einen Container
und wandern
am Schweizer Nationalfeiertag 2012
in ihrer neuen Heimat Belize ein.
Für mich war Belize
Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
Das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Die Familie
hat vorerst nur ihr Gepäck.
Der Container ist noch unterwegs.
Logischerweise war alles leer.
Es gab noch keine Möbel.
Aber das wussten wir.
Wir hatten Luftmatratzen dabei.
Am Anfang
schliefen wir auf Luftmatratzen.
Der grosse Schock kommt erst später.
Für die Einfuhr ihres Hab und Guts
zahlen sie trotz Vorabklärungen
20'000 Fr. mehr als budgetiert.
Bei gewissen Sachen
haben wir zu viel bezahlt.
Der Verkäufer des Landes
wollte uns über den Tisch ziehen.
Letztlich blechen Balmers doppelt
so viel wie ein Einheimischer.
Dafür besitzen sie nun
ein riesiges Stück Land,
grösser als sechs Fussballfelder,
gleich neben der Hauptstadt
von Belize: Belmopan.
Und doch leben die Balmers
mitten im Dschungel.
Diesem Dschungel
das Land zu entreissen,
ist eine Aufgabe, die Fritz
seit sechs Jahren in Atem hält.
Das ist mein ewiger Krieg hier.
Ist dieser Krieg zu gewinnen?
An diesem Fleck vielleicht schon,
aber dann beginne ich dort wieder,
wo ich vorher war.
Nicht wahr?
Obwohl er körperlich härter schuftet
als noch als Betriebsleiter
in der Logistik,
ist Fritz hier glücklicher
als in der Schweiz.
Es wurde mir schlichtweg zu eng,
alles ist limitiert,
für alles gibt es
zwei oder drei Gesetze,
für alles blechst und bezahlst du.
Hier hat man all das nicht.
Hier hat Fritz die Musse,
auch die kleinen Dinge zu geniessen.
Das ist eine Autobahn
von Blattschneiderameisen.
* Fritz lacht. *
Eine so kleine Ameise
und ein so grosses Blatt.
* Bellen *
Rambo!
Lasst das Eichhörnchen in Ruhe!
* Bellen *
Yes, hello?
Yes.
Was für ein Brot
möchten sie versuchen?
Wir haben verschiedene Sorten.
Ich bringe eine Auswahl.
Ein potenzieller Kunde ist am Draht.
Thank you so much.
Okay, bye-bye.
Bye-bye!
Das war wieder mal was!
Hier in Belize
läuft alles über Connections.
Er hat sich daran erinnert,
dass wir eine Bäckerei haben.
Die Bäckerei befindet sich
in diesem kleinen Häuschen.
* Fetzige Musik *
Brigittes Sohn Johnny
ist hier der Chef.
Balmers haben kein Verkaufsgeschäft,
sondern liefern nur auf Bestellung -
an Supermärkte und Hotels.
* Fetzige Musik *
In der Küche machen Francine
und Nathalie ihre Aufgaben.
Francine geht noch zur Schule.
Nathalie schloss die Highschool im
Fach Wirtschaft als Klassenbeste ab
und studiert jetzt Wirtschafts-
wissenschaften an der Uni.
Sie hat einen Freund: Giovanni.
Er ist eigentlich
einfach einer von unserer Familie.
Ja.
Nach bald zwei Jahren
ist das schon so, ja.
Er ist auch viel bei uns zu Hause.
Ja, er gehört einfach zu uns.
Have a good time!
Nathalies Freund Giovanni
ist in Belize ein Velochampion.
Er wurde dieses Jahr Landesmeister
im Einzelzeitfahren.
Der Sohn
des nationalen Sicherheitschefs
träumt von der Tour de France.
Brigitte
ist wie eine Mutter für mich.
Sie unterstützt mich in allem -
auch dem Radfahren.
Sie wird bald
meine Schwiegermutter sein.
Nathalie und ich
wollen demnächst heiraten.
* Lachen im Hintergrund *
Ich weiss noch nichts davon!
(Brigitte) She's waiting!
Ich bin nicht am Warten.
Giovanni fährt nun für ein paar Tage
ins Trainingslager.
So hat die fünfköpfige Familie
für einen Moment wieder mehr Platz -
neben den vielen Tieren,
die auch auf der Farm leben.
* Lockere Musik *
Mit zwei haben wir angefangen,
jetzt sind es acht.
* Lachen *
Sie ist ein bisschen speziell. Sie
meint, sie sei unser neunter Hund.
Unser Dalmatiner.
Du wolltest raus,
also dann geh raus!
Geh raus! Los!
Geh raus! Raus!
Ich packe dich an den Ohren.
Geh zurück!
Hopp! Hopp!
Da muss ich mich
als Bullendompteur betätigen.
Oder?
In der Hauptstadt Belmopan
wird heute der Tag der Unabhängigkeit
gefeiert.
Also mein Herz schlägt schon mehr
für Belize, als für die Schweiz.
Inmitten der Parade:
Brigittes Tochter Francine.
Sie führt ihre Schule
ganz vorne mit an.
In Belize
wohnen keine 400'000 Menschen.
Johnny liefert das Gebäck aus.
Ich habe alles vorbereitet.
Die Rechnung ist geschrieben -
bis auf das, was ich retour nehme.
Die nicht verkauften Produkte
muss Johnny zurücknehmen -
das ist der Deal mit dem Supermarkt.
In Belize kennt man keine Backwaren
wie bei uns.
Johnny muss immer wieder
hartes Brot essen.
Ich finde, es ist halt schon
ein schweres Business.
Ich weiss, die Leute,
die es probieren,
lieben die Produkte, sie mögen sie.
Aber bis sie mal probieren ...
Das ist das Problem.
Siehst du,
jetzt wurde gerade eines verkauft.
Thank you. Have a nice day.
Den Kampf gegen die Tortillas
haben sich die Balmers
etwas einfacher vorgestellt.
Doch auch das nicht verkaufte Brot
findet seine Abnehmer.
Wir haben eigentlich praktisch
nichts, was wir wegwerfen.
Stimmt's?
Fertig. Schluss. Aus.
Nein, anständig!
Anständig.
Schwein Specky isst den Rest.
Es ist kein feudales Leben,
dass die Balmers führen.
Wir verhungern sicher nicht.
Und verdursten
müssen wir auch nicht,
aber wir müssen immer schauen.
Die Bäckerei kann die Familie
noch nicht ernähren, nein.
Das Ersparte
ist schon lange aufgebraucht.
Wir haben das grosse Glück,
dass wir ...
Wir haben in der Schweiz eine
Wohnung, die wir vermietet haben.
Wir leben vom Mietzins
dieser Wohnung.
Aber mir macht es Spass.
Ich bin ...
Ich blühe hier eigentlich auf.
Es ist schön.
Ich geniesse diese Freiheit.
Das ist für mich Reichtum.
Lebensqualität pur -
auch wenn man dafür
ein bisschen krampfen muss.
* Sanfte Musik *
Trotz Geldsorgen -
im Dschungel von Belize
scheint es Familie Balmer
gut zu gehen.
Sie verzichtet auf Luxus
und lebt trotz engem Raum
ihre grosse Freiheit.
Viel ist es nicht, was die Balmers
aus ihrer alten Heimat vermissen.
Im Gegenteil:
Sie schätzen das einfache Leben.
Uns hat das Ganze
sicher zusammengeschweisst.
Wenn man miteinander
schmal durchmuss ...
Miteinander ...
Wenn man schauen muss,
wie man durchkommt,
dann geht das nur miteinander.
Uns hat das Auswandern eine andere
Sicht vom ganzen Leben gegeben:
was leben bedeutet.
Das bedeutet nicht Geld
oder Reichtum,
sondern Freiheit.
Stimmt's?
- Ja.
* Lockere Musik *
Freiheit statt Reichtum -
das passt auch gut Familie Ruckstuhl,
die ich jetzt besuche.
Wir haben sie 2016
bei "Auf und davon" kennengelernt.
* Lockere Musik *
Ruckstuhls wohnen
in der Nähe der Kleinstadt Nanton,
in der Provinz Alberta.
Ich weiss von Ruckstuhls,
dass sie viel Platz ums Haus haben,
aber doch eher eine kleine Wohnung,
in der sie zur Miete leben.
Dass es Wichtigeres
als Reichtum gibt,
haben sie auch
aus einem Schicksalsschlag gelernt:
Ihre ältere Tochter Josephine
hat eine schwere Erbkrankheit.
Oh, schau! Sie sind schon da.
Josephine und ihre Schwester Elena
holen mich ab.
Hallo!
* Mona lacht. *
Hi! Hi, hi!
Da steigen wir rasch aus.
Machen wir das schnell!
Hey, hey! Hallihallo!
It's ...
... Josephine and Elena.
Hallihallo. Ich bin Mona.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Hallo! Hallihallo zusammen!
Was macht ihr hier?
Meine Schwester hat das Auto
zum Geburtstag erhalten.
Elena ist jetzt vier Jahre alt.
Du bist vier Jahre alt. Super!
Das war ein Geburtstagsgeschenk?
Wow!
* Heitere Musik *
Schau auf die Strasse!
Ihr habt das super gemacht!
Ich habe es gut gefunden.
Vielen Dank!
Markus. Hallo, ich bin Mona.
Alexandra, schön, dich zu sehen.
Ich bin Mona. Freut mich sehr.
Habt ihr immer
so ein Empfangskomitee?
Wenn sie es früh genug sehen.
Sie freuen sich, wenn Besuch kommt.
Grossartig!
Where are we going to?
- In the barn.
Scheu sind die beiden Mädchen nicht.
There, chicken!
Ah, dort sind die Hühner?
* Lautes Krähen *
Es ist alles andere
als selbstverständlich,
dass es Josephine so gut geht.
How many?
- Two.
Sie leidet
an einer Stoffwechselkrankheit.
Dank einer Stammzelltransplantation
kann sie heute so herumhüpfen.
Josephines Schicksal prägte
die Auswanderung von Ruckstuhls.
Für ihre Behandlung
kehrten sie in die Schweiz zurück,
um dann ein zweites Mal auszuwandern.
Dieses Mal für immer.
* Fröhliches Schreien *
Hello!
Hello! Good to see you again.
- Good to see you.
Welcome back.
Der erste Spitalbesuch für Josephine
nach ihrer definitiven Auswanderung.
Sag "Hallo!", das kannst du doch.
Du schaust gesund und gut aus.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie alles gelaufen ist.
Gibt es Anlass zur Sorge?
Das Herz ist gut. Die Lungen
sind gut, die Leber, die Niere.
Alles ist gut.
Da war Flüssigkeit in ihrem Gehirn.
Sagten die Schweizer Ärzte,
dass das behandelt werden muss?
Sie sagten, dass es
auf dem letzten MRI besser aussah.
Wenn du dich gerade so wohlfühlst,
dann wollen wir dich
doch gleich untersuchen.
Josephine leidet
an einer sehr seltenen Krankheit
namens Hurler-Syndrom.
Der Stoffwechsel
funktioniert nicht richtig.
Die gesamte Entwicklung
ist deshalb verlangsamt.
Schwachpunkte sind u.a. die Knochen
und die Gelenke.
Wie eine Prinzessinnenkrone!
Es ist
eine endlose Krankheitsgeschichte.
Josephine wird immer in
ärztlicher Behandlung bleiben müssen.
(Computerstimme)
Please, say a command!
Call Honey!
(Computerstimme) Calling Honey.
(Markus) Hallo. Ging es gut?
Ja, Jojo war mega lieb.
Sie war geduldig.
Blut haben sie keines genommen.
Aber jetzt kommt natürlich referred
to this and referred to that
and we're gonna be back
a million times.
Ja.
Tschüss!
- Fahr gut! Tschüss!
Ciao.
Josephines Krankheit
sollte jedoch kein Hindernis sein,
nicht doch auszuwandern.
Darin waren sich Alexandra und Markus
einig.
Beide waren sie immer
fasziniert von Kanada.
Zudem sahen sie als Bauern
in der Schweiz keine Perspektive.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Beim traditionellen Branding, bei dem
die Kälber ihr Brandmal erhalten,
ist Markus fast der Einzige
ohne Cowboyhut.
* Muhen *
Markus hat eine feste Anstellung
bei einem Grossfarmer und liebt es,
die monströsen Mähdrescher zu fahren.
They told me,
I can go the other way.
* Dynamische Musik *
Die ersten Kindheitsjahre
waren streng.
Nun kann Josephine
mit ihrer Schwester Elena
das Leben immer mehr geniessen -
dank der gut verlaufenden Behandlung.
Sie wäre jeden Tag krank und würde
sich auch nicht weiterentwickeln.
Sie macht jeden Tag Fortschritte.
Ohne unseren ...
Ohne unseren Helden
würde sie das nicht machen.
Der Held ist
der unbekannte Stammzellenspender.
Ein Held, den die Familie
nie kennenlernen wird.
Ein Unbekannter,
der das Leben der Familie Ruckstuhl
aber für immer reicher gemacht hat.
Es ist ein Geschenk, das wir unser
ganzes Leben lang täglich haben.
Das ist ...
Dafür gibt es nur Dankbarkeit.
Das ist ungla...
Also, ja.
Er weiss gar nicht,
was er für uns gemacht hat.
Ich hoffe, er weiss es.
Er weiss es nicht wirklich -
ausser er würde uns kennenlernen.
* Beschwingte Banjomusik *
Markus möchte gerne eine Kuh kaufen.
Die Ruckstuhls haben das Ziel,
sich so weit wie möglich
selbst versorgen zu können -
mit Gemüse, Eiern und auch Milch.
(Markus)
Wie viel möchtest du für die Kuh?
2'800 Dollar.
2'800?
Oh, das ist viel Geld!
Das sind schon fast
Schweizer Preise.
Ich dachte an etwa 2'000 oder 2'200.
Aber das sind ...
Sie haben
vor drei Monaten gekalbert.
Sie geben schon etwas Milch.
Markus macht Fotos,
um die Angelegenheit mit Alexandra
besprechen zu können.
Auf welche Seite muss ich?
Was? Nicht zwei, oder?
- Nein.
Die beiden wären zur Auswahl.
Die eine ...
Beide sind fünf Jahre alt,
haben vor drei Monaten gekalbert.
Er will dafür 2'800 Stutz.
Ja, gut, aber das ist normal.
Wie viel Milch geben sie im Moment?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Sie haben ein grosses Euter.
Hast du nicht gefragt?
- Nein.
Die einen Kühe
können nach dem Kalbern 50 l geben,
andere geben 15 l am Tag.
- Das sind ...
20 l gibt sie sicher.
Du musst dich halten.
Der grosse Traum
der Familie Ruckstuhl wäre es,
eines Tages
eine eigene kleine Farm zu besitzen,
auf der Josephine und Elena
glücklich aufwachsen können.
Oh-oh!
* Die Katze miaut. *
He's gonna bite you.
Was die Tiere angeht,
haben Ruckstuhls
in den letzten Jahren
schon recht aufgerüstet.
Ihr habt einen richtigen Bauernhof.
- Eher einen Streichelzoo.
Aufpassen! Wenn er abhaut,
sind die Hunde schnell da.
Würden sie die Hasen gleich nehmen?
Ja, sie sind einmal ... Die ersten
haben sich mal ausgegraben.
Sie sind nicht weit gekommen.
- Was?
Haben die Hunde sie geholt?
- Ja.
Wir legen ihn wieder zurück,
sonst haut er ab.
Wir geben ihm noch frisches Gras.
* Drollige Musik *
* Unverständliches Kinderbrabbeln *
Josephine
ist schon fast sechs Jahre alt
und seit einem halben Jahr
stolze Kindergärtnerin.
Wie ist es für Jo im Kindergarten?
Sie ist an der ganzen Schule
das kleinste Kind.
Alle Kinder aus allen Klassen
kennen Jo. Alle sagen Hallo zu ihr.
Sie ist ein kleiner Superstar.
Es gibt ein paar Mädchen, ich glaube
aus der dritten Klasse, die warten,
bis sie aus dem Schulbus kommt:
"Jo is coming!"
Sie helfen ihr beim Reinlaufen.
Ich glaube, sie findet das cool.
Und ist es nun eher besser,
als dass ihr es erwartet habt?
Es ist das, was wir gehofft haben.
Also ... Wie sagt man?
Expect the worst, hope for the best.
Wir haben das Schlimmste erwartet,
aber gehofft, dass es kommt,
wie es ist. So ist es nun.
Und jetzt, ja ...
Sie macht in der Schule
gute Fortschritte.
Sie braucht für alles etwas länger.
Wegen ihrer eingeschränkten Gelenke
kann sie sich nicht selbst anziehen.
Wegen ihrem Rücken
kann sie ihre Füsse nicht berühren.
Es ist alles ein Krampf für sie.
Andere Fünfjährige ziehen sich
selbst an, sie kann das nicht.
Markus macht das Pferd bereit,
um mit den Kindern auszureiten.
* Heitere Banjoklänge *
* Mona lacht. *
Ah, jetzt, Achtung!
- (Elena) Auch mitmachen!
Mine!
* Mona lacht. *
Das sieht etwas doof aus.
Der steht dir viel besser.
So machen wir das.
Hol noch rasch die anderen Steig-
bügel, die ich dir gegeben habe!
Reiten ist etwas,
das Josephine besonders guttut.
Es fördert die Beweglichkeit
und trainiert die Gelenke.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Auf mich wirkt Josephine,
als ob es ihr bestens geht,
aber Markus widerspricht mir.
Erst vor ein paar Wochen
sei Josephine
an beiden Handgelenken
operiert worden.
Es ist halt ein ewiges Werk mit ihr.
Sie wird immer Beeinträchtigungen
haben - auch im Körperbau.
Und auch in der Schule kommt sie
weniger gut mit, braucht Förderung.
Wenn man nicht hineinsieht,
sieht vieles anders aus.
Wir sind jeden Monat
mindestens einmal in Calgary -
im Winter noch öfters -
für Check-ups und Untersuchungen.
Okay.
Jo wird ein Leben lang ...
Wir wissen noch nicht,
wie es mit ihr wird.
Wir nehmen es einfach so,
wie es kommt.
* Sanfte Musik *
Gipsy!
Aus!
Rein da! Hopp jetzt!
Frühmorgens. Alexandra
schaut zu Hause zu den Tieren.
Markus ist unterwegs zur Arbeit.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir fahren zur grossen Weide.
Das ist staatliches Land,
wo die Rinder von Markus' Chef
während des Sommers grasen dürfen.
In regelmässigen Abständen
muss Markus kontrollieren,
ob mit den Tieren
alles in Ordnung ist -
mit dem Pferd, wie es sich
für einen richtigen Cowboy gehört.
Und jetzt trägt Markus
auch den passenden Hut.
Hätte dir
vor 15 Jahren jemand gesagt,
dass du mal als Cowboy in Kanada
wärst, was hättest du gesagt?
Na ja ...
Ich wäre nicht abgeneigt gewesen.
Wirklich?
- Nein.
Bei mir hat das mit Kanada schon
in der Sekundarschule begonnen.
Das war ein Traum. Rodeos und ...
Ich habe damals schon
einen Vortrag über Rodeos gemacht.
Wirklich?
- Ja, ja.
Woher kommt das denn?
- Ich weiss auch nicht. Das ist ...
Aus den Filmen,
vom Fernsehen vielleicht.
Auch ich muss reiten.
Markus gibt mir
das liebste Pferd von allen.
Ein Sofa auf vier Beinen, sagt er.
* Lockere Musik *
Achtung!
So!
Die Mädchen schlafen noch,
als Alexandra zum Melken geht.
Alexandra
ist auf einem Bauernhof aufgewachsen.
Aber mit 16 rebellierte sie
und zog aus,
um eine Kochlehre zu machen. Sie habe
als Kind einen sturen Kopf gehabt.
Ich denke,
unsere Mädchen haben sicher ...
... sicher auch einen sturen Kopf.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl ...
Ich weiss auch nicht, aber ...
Es bringt dich im Leben weiter.
Wenn du immer nachgibst oder
keinen Plan und keine Idee hast
und dich nicht durchsetzen kannst,
kommst du nirgendwohin.
Es ist gut - v.a. auch für Jo.
Wenn sie
immer wieder an Barrieren stösst,
bei denen sie wegen ihres Körpers,
wegen ihrer Krankheit
nicht weitermachen kann,
ist es gut, wenn sie stur ist
und einen anderen Weg finden
und trotzdem an ihrem Plan
oder an ihrer Idee festhalten kann.
* Schnauben *
Sicher?
* Lockere Musik *
Knapp eine Stunde
sind wir schon auf dem Pferd.
Wo sind jetzt diese Kühe?
Na ja,
es ist ein relativ grosses Feld.
Ich weiss nicht genau, wie gross.
Aber
es sind ein paar Hundert Hektaren,
auf denen die 300 Kühe sind.
- Ja.
Komm!
Unter Umständen suchst du lange.
Ja.
Wir hören jetzt das Muhen.
- Ja.
Irgendwo sollten sie schon sein.
Unter die 300 Kühe
mischte sich noch ein Fremdling.
Jetzt ist der Nachbarsstier hier.
Woher kommt der denn?
Von weiter vorne. Er ist schon
länger hier als unsere Stiere.
Oh ja, sieh mal!
Er ist schon bei der Arbeit.
Was machst du?
- Nichts. Ich schaue mal.
Ich schaue jeweils,
wie es unseren Stieren geht.
Ob sie verletzt sind.
Also, ob sie einen Unfall hatten
oder eine Verletzung haben, aber ...
Das ist dir egal, wenn
ein fremder Stier auf eure Kühe ...
Ja, Hauptsache, sie trägt.
Also.
- Ist gut.
Gehen wir weiter!
Der Brunstruf.
* Lauter Brunstruf *
Irgendwo muss der Zaun kaputt sein,
dass der fremde Stier
überhaupt hier reingekommen ist.
Hier ist kein Strom drauf.
Schauen wir schnell,
ob sie nirgendwo abgehauen sind!
Na ja, schnell ...
Das würde ich nicht sagen.
Wir können es versuchen.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Drollige Musik *
Hey!
What the fuck! Wieso sind die raus?
Gipsy, komm hierher! Sitz!
* Krähen *
Du meine Güte!
Ah, du Viech!
Ach!
Warte jetzt!
Wo seid ihr raus, ihr blöden Tiere?
Jetzt habt ihr Pech gehabt.
Jetzt seid ihr Hundefutter.
Na ja, selber schuld!
Hier drin wären sie sicher,
aber wenn sie draussen sind,
sind sie Hundefutter.
Dumm gelaufen.
* Lockere Musik *
Markus und ich kontrollieren
immer noch die Zäune und Herden.
Reiten, auf dem Pferd zu sitzen -
ist das für dich arbeiten?
Na ja, fast nicht.
Ich traue mich fast nicht,
die Stunden aufzuschreiben.
* Lockere Musik *
Alles gut?
- Ja, so weit schon, ja.
Dieses Elchgeweih ist das erste,
das Markus hier in Kanada findet.
Was machst du jetzt damit?
Wir setzen es zu Hause
in ein Blumenbeet.
* Mona lacht. *
Was?
Alexandra.
- Ist das ein Geschenk für Alexandra?
Ja, genau.
Es ist ein Ausstellungsstück.
Freut sie sich über solche Dinge?
- Na ja, nicht unbedingt, aber ...
Aber du?
- Ja. Es ist doch schön.
* Lockere Musik *
Schau mal! Das hat Papa gefunden.
In den Bergen bei den Kühen.
Was ist das?
A horn.
- A horn.
It's an antler. Ein Geweih.
- A tiny one and a bigger one.
That's a big one.
- Jetzt bringst du es Mami?
Zeigst du es Mami?
- Ja. Let's go!
Ja.
Sie macht gerade Kekse.
- Cookies?
Ja.
A big horn.
- Let me see!
It's a moose horn.
Oh, it's heavy! Nice!
Das ist gross.
- Ja.
Weisst du,
was für ein Riesentier das war?
Wir stellen es in den Garten, oder?
For decoration.
Ja.
Stellst du es hinaus,
oder soll ich das machen?
I.
- Geht es?
Hm, es riecht gut!
Geht es?
- Ja.
So!
Auch für die beiden Hunde
hat Markus ein Präsent: Hasenfleisch.
Ob das wohl hilft,
den Jagdtrieb der Hunde zu senken?
* Lockere Musik *
Josephine schaut, wie ihre Eltern
ein neues Gehege bauen -
nicht für die Hasen,
sondern für die Truthähne.
Die buddeln sich
garantiert nicht raus.
Beim Ehepaar Ruckstuhl
können beide anpacken -
einfach auf eine andere Art.
Hast du nicht
denselben Abstand eingehalten?
Ich habe jeweils drei gemacht.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Die einen sind eben grösser.
- Ja ...
Meinst du, die Turkeys finden das
ästhetisch nicht so schön?
Nein.
- Ob sie das stört?
Ich gehe raus.
Kannst du es mir durchreichen?
Wir sind ein relativ gutes Team.
Ich bin meist
ein bisschen zu perfekt.
Genau.
- Und sie macht hopp, hopp.
Eben! Wenn es Markus
zu perfekt machen will,
was dann auch oft heisst, dass es
kompliziert wird und ewig dauert,
bin ich eher diejenige, die will:
"Let's get this done!",
und dann ist es gut.
Und dann
machen wir so ein Mittelmass.
Wir finden jeweils schon einen Weg.
Es wäre ja nicht normal,
wenn man alles gleich sehen würde.
Mommy, are we going home?
- Soon.
Willst du es versuchen?
- No.
I got it.
- Doch, schneid du!
- Gut!
Aber jetzt wird es anstrengend.
Willst du den
etwa von Hand schieben?
Ja.
- Das kannst du selbst machen.
Ein starker Kerl!
- Du hast doch die Anhängerkupplung.
Damit kannst du es machen.
Schau zu!
- Geh beiseite, Ela!
Puh!
Du bist ein Trottel, ehrlich.
- Es tut nur an den Fingern weh.
Dann zieh Handschuhe an!
- Kannst du hinten stossen, bitte?
Langsam, langsam!
Puh!
* Lockere Musik *
Man kann vieles verwirklichen,
wenn man nur richtig anpackt.
Aber bei etwas sind Ruckstuhls
noch nicht weitergekommen:
Sie konnten
noch kein eigenes Haus kaufen.
Die Preise
seien einfach viel zu hoch,
da reiche Städter aus dem nahen
Calgary sich hier in der Umgebung
gerne Ferienhäuser kaufen.
Aber auch das
müsse nicht nur schlecht sein.
Ob dieser Traum einer eigenen Farm
so ein Traum ist
oder wir mehr Freiheiten haben,
weil wir nicht ...
Ich denke,
wir haben so mehr Freiheiten.
Wir müssen weniger bangen und ...
Ja.
Aber ich sage, wir sind auf dem Weg.
Aber wir werden unseren Traum
sowieso nie erreichen.
Dann haben wir den nächsten Plan.
- Ja.
Wenn wir alles haben,
verkaufen wir alles
und gehen nach Australien
oder machen irgend so einen Mist.
Die neuesten Pläne
flatterten uns ein paar Monate
nach den Dreharbeiten ins Haus.
Keine Farm,
auch nicht Australien, nein.
Ende März gibt es nochmals
einen kleinen Ruckstuhl.
* Lockere Musik *
* Sanfte Popmusik *
Jetzt sind wir schon auf der
letzten Etappe unserer Kanada-Reise
zum "Auf und davon"-Jubiläum.
Sie führt mich dorthin zurück,
wo wir angefangen haben.
Zum nördlichsten Punkt unserer Reise:
zu den endlosen Wäldern von Rosswood
und seinen Bewohnern.
* Sanfte Popmusik *
Ich habe Familie Schönbächler
ja versprochen, zurückzukehren -
und ihr einen Überraschungsgast
mitzubringen.
Also ich bin auch etwas angespannt,
wie diese Überraschung ankommt.
Hoffentlich
kennen sie ihn überhaupt noch!
Gölä.
* Gitarrenmusik *
Göläs Song "Uf u dervo"
ist mit unserer Auswanderersendung
fest verbunden.
Was die meisten nicht wissen:
Gölä nahm dieses Lied
vor zehn Jahren fürs Fernsehen
extra in einer neuen Version auf.
Heute zeigen wir zum ersten Mal
das Filmmaterial,
wie dieser Song entstand.
# Ines Land ohni Näbu, ohni Räge.
- Nein, das ist zu viel.
Aber das ist doch cool.
Da haben wir ein Soundlike.
Es tönt wie das Original.
# U si stige in Flüger
und flüged mit de Vögu furt.
# U si chöme nüme hei.
Ja, oder? Damit es ähnlich tönt,
aber auf deine Sendung
abgestimmt ist.
Ja, genau. Das ist super!
One, two!
Hey, hey, hey!
Ba-ba-ba-bap. Bloody hell!
# U si löh ...
Ach! Wait, wait, wait!
# U si löh hie alles ...
# U si löh hie alles zrüg.
One, two, three!
Is that right, chicks?
# U si stige in Flüger,
flüged mit de Vögu furt.
# Chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie alles zrüg.
# Uf dr Suechi für nes nois Dihei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uh-uh-uh.
# Eifach uf u dervo.
Yeah!
Neben diesem Lied verbindet Gölä aber
noch was anderes mit "Auf und davon".
Er träumt selber immer wieder
vom Auswandern -
nach Australien, Neuseeland, Kanada
oder wenigstens mal
mit dem Schiff um die Welt.
Getan hat er das aber
bis heute noch nicht.
Beim Rosswood General Store
haben wir mit Gölä
und seiner ganzen Familie abgemacht.
Hier sind sie! Hallo zusammen!
Schön, dich zu sehen, Gölä!
V.a. hier draussen.
- Ja, wir freuen uns auch.
Heidi! Freut mich!
- Hallo, Mona!
Das ist Nikki, oder?
Das ist Leslie. Hallo, hallo!
Du!
Du bist mit der ganzen Familie
unterwegs und nicht wegen uns hier.
Nein.
- Was macht ihr hier?
Wir sind mit den Eltern hier.
Wir reisten mit ihnen nach Banff.
Sie sind schon ziemlich alt.
Mein Vater ist 80.
- Warum nach Banff?
Weil meine Schwester
schon ewig dort lebt.
Also deine Schwester
ist ausgewandert?
Ja, sie lebt schon seit Ewigkeiten
in Kanada.
Sie lebt in Banff. Und meine Eltern
schafften es nie, hierherzureisen.
Da sagten wir uns,
dass wir ihnen helfen.
Wir reisten mit ihnen hierhin
und werden mit ihnen zurückreisen.
* Klappern *
Nimmst du das Lokal auseinander?
* Lachen *
Jetzt besuchen wir ja Schönbächlers.
Ja.
- Hermann.
Die
berühmt-berüchtigten Schönbächlers.
Das ist cool.
- Was glaubt ihr?
Was ist das für einer?
Ich glaube, er ist urchig.
Ja, aber das Bild,
das ich von ihm gesehen habe ...
Er ist eigentlich mehr Kanadier
als die anderen Typen,
die wir gesehen haben.
- Unterwegs.
Unterwegs.
- Ja.
Wir helfen den Kanadiern mit ihm,
dass sie richtige Kanadier werden.
Du, ich glaube, wir gehen, oder?
- Ja.
Kann ich noch meinen Kaffee trinken?
- Du kannst ihn mitnehmen.
Hier ist alles to go.
Du kannst ihn mitnehmen.
Gölä sagt, er habe keinen Fernseher.
Aber er kennt Hermann Schönbächler -
und auch dessen Sprüche.
Ja, hier ist es noch wild, oder?
- Herrlich!
Die ultimative Lebensqualität!
Wir würden hier nicht auffallen.
Schau, ein Bär!
- Ein Bär!
Hast du gesehen? Schau, dieser Bär!
Ein schöner Bär!
Warte, hier war er!
Schau, da ist er! Da!
Hallo, Bär!
Schau da! Ein schönes Tier!
- Ja.
Ein Bär.
- Wieder ein junger.
Ja. Ah, dort hinten ist er.
- Siehst du ihn?
Ja.
Ich wollte gerade fluchen,
dass keine Tiere da sind.
Das wäre zu früh gewesen.
Dann die Abzweigung
zu Familie Schönbächler.
Er hat die Stämme sauber unters Dach
gestapelt - nicht wie die anderen.
Ja, das ist eben ein Schweizer.
- Ja.
Sauber aufgeräumt. Das gefällt mir!
Was kommen da für Autos?
Jetzt bin ich trotzdem neugierig.
Also ... Ah, okay!
Das ist ...
Das ist Mona.
Komm, fahr etwas nach vorne!
* Gölä lacht laut. *
Hallo zusammen!
- Ich habe es geahnt.
So? Ich habe schon gedacht,
dass du das weisst.
Ja, ja. Ja, ja. Ja, ja.
Kann ich die Karre dort hinstellen?
- Ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
- Tipptopp!
Wir werweissten heute Morgen noch.
Aber die Überraschung ist gelungen.
Ah,
die Kinder lasse ich auch noch raus!
Schau, die ganze Familie. So cool!
- Schau! Endlich Kinder!
Bravo!
Komm, wir gehen Hallo sagen!
Hallo! Gölä! Freut mich!
- Freut mich!
Hallo!
- Grüss dich!
Freut mich! So, jetzt sehe ich dich
mal live, du fauler Mensch!
Gleichfalls!
- Du siehst gut aus!
"Du fauler Mensch" - jawohl!
Hallo! Gölä!
Hallo! Gölä! Geht es dir gut?
Eine coole Sache!
Wir diskutierten heute Morgen noch
und blieben bei ihm hängen.
Ehrlich?
- Ja.
Als die Frage kam:
"Hast du denn Bier?"
Genau! Das war ein Hinweis.
* Lachen *
Nicht, dass ich dich mit einem
Biersäufer assoziieren würde.
Ja, aber sie schreiben alle nur ...
- Aber das ist irgendwie ...
Das ist so das, was du verkörperst.
Ja. Es stimmt zwar nicht.
Ja.
Aber ich mag Bier lieber
als Champagner.
Ich auch.
- Eben!
Verdammt schön habt ihr es hier!
Ruhig! Es ist der Hammer!
Die Kinder
haben null Berührungsängste.
Und auch die Männer
finden schnell Gemeinsamkeiten.
Wo wohnst du jetzt?
In Leissigen/BE, auf dem Hügel.
- Leissigen?
Ja, das liegt auf 800 m ü.M. und hat
im Winter drei Monate keine Sonne.
Das ist etwas mühsam.
Aber wir haben keinen Strom-
oder Wasseranschluss, nichts.
Tipptopp!
Wir sind für uns im Wald, weisst du?
Wenn du auf unseren 4 ha ...
Unten ist das Dorf Leissigen.
Und wir sind oben auf 800 m ü.M.
Nicht mal der Postbote kommt.
Ich muss die Strasse selber räumen.
Ja, das ist ...
- Das ist der Hammer!
Wie ich auch.
- Keine Sau kommt.
Das habe ich gar nicht gewusst.
Für uns
ist es ein kleines Bisschen Kanada.
Es ist einfach herrlich!
Ich möchte nicht in Spiez wohnen.
20 Minuten mit dem Auto, und dort
möchte ich schon nicht mehr leben.
Schon zu viele Leute?
- Ja.
Wirklich?
Was stören euch diese Leute
denn immer?
Das habe ich euch auch schon gefragt.
Ich kenne v.a. nette Leute.
Aber ihr wollt
möglichst weit weg von ihnen.
Es hat etwas Schönes
und Befreiendes,
wenn du keine Vorhänge brauchst.
Ehrlich!
Gölä sagt, wenn er splitternackt
durch die Hütte rennen könne,
sei es gut.
Es ist so!
Du kannst es dir ansehen.
Ich habe ihn gekauft,
aber die Polizei nahm ihn mir weg.
* Gölä lacht. *
Wenn dir dieses Zeug hier
etwas sagt, das hier drauf ist.
Oh, schön!
- Das ist eine 350er.
Was verhandeln sie dort?
Sie fachsimpeln.
Das ist gut. Die kannst du jetzt für
den Rest der Zeit in Ruhe lassen.
Wie Kinder.
Das ist eben so mein Ding.
- So sah mein K5 aus.
Aber er war kürzer.
Er kam etwa bis hierher.
- Jawohl.
Davon gab es auch Shortboxes.
Der K5 war auf dem Shortbox-Chassis.
Genau.
- Genau. Jawohl.
Das sind geile Maschinen.
- Ja.
Aber er flog mir auseinander.
- Ja, ja.
Es stimmt - für die grossen
und die kleinen Kinder.
Tipptopp!
Der Abenteuerspielplatz hier
ist ein Traum für alle -
auch für die Töchter von Gölä
und Heidi:
die fünfjährige Leslie
und Nikki, die sechs Jahre alt ist.
Habt ihr auch einen Traum,
bei dem ihr sagt:
"Irgendwann hauen wir auch mal ab
und fangen irgendwo neu an!"?
Ja ...
V.a. er.
- Zieht es ihn mehr weg?
Ja, ihn zieht es mehr weg.
Dort, wo wir sind,
bin ich happy und zufrieden.
Es reicht mir eigentlich.
V.a. haben wir
diesen Ort in der Schweiz.
Aber ihn zieht es schon noch weg.
Es geht noch etwas. Ich spüre es.
Kommt dieses Thema Auswandern
immer wieder?
Ja, ja. Ja, es kommt immer wieder.
Ich habe zu ihm gesagt:
"Wir sind ein Team."
"Und dann
müssen wir uns schon einigen."
Und ich habe ihm gesagt:
"Ich komme mit dir."
"Dort, wo du bist, bin ich auch."
Jetzt mal sehen, was passiert.
Eben, du bist etwas skeptisch.
Du möchtest nicht
aus der Schweiz weg.
V.a. haben wir in der Schweiz
das schönste Zuhause,
das man haben kann.
Eben, wenn ihr euren Traum
dort schon gefunden habt.
Ich bin so eine richtige
Urschweizerin, habe ich das Gefühl.
Du siehst nicht so aus.
Ja ... Eben!
Doch, hier: das Edelweiss.
- Jawohl, schön!
Irgendwann
kommt noch eine Ziege dazu.
* Lockere Musik *
Was ist das für Holz?
Gölä heizt in seinem abgelegenen Haus
am Thunersee
auch mit Holz
und muss dafür
immer wieder mal eine Tanne fällen.
Also packt er die Chance für eine
Weiterbildung in Sachen Baumfällen -
beim diplomierten Forstwart und
Meister aller Kettensägen: Hermann.
* Lockere Musik *
Halt, halt, halt, halt!
Das ist nur die Fallkerbe.
Was? Ich weiss.
- Er geht nicht so weit rein.
Einfach Bauernholzer, ja?
Ich bin ein Bauernholzer.
Du musst hier hinstehen.
- Gut.
Und mit schiebender Kette, ja.
Auf welcher Höhe?
Auf derselben Höhe?
Halbe Höhe Fallkerbe. Hier.
- Gut.
Halt!
Baum fällt!
Ja, ja, eben!
* Motorsäge stellt ab. *
Also!
* Gölä lacht. *
Offensichtlich spielst du besser
Gitarre, als dass du Bäume fällst.
Bis jetzt ging es ganz gut.
Aber ich muss auf den Profi hören.
Hier hätte man
so ein schönes Loch gehabt,
in das man den Baum
hätte fallen lassen können.
Jetzt hängst du den Baum
in diese Staude.
Ja, wo du recht hast, hast du recht.
- Ja.
Gut, jetzt gehen wir zum nächsten!
- Nein.
Doch, jetzt, da ich es gelernt habe!
- Nein, jetzt räumen wir den auf.
Also gut!
Du musst so schneiden. Schau!
Hermann zeigt Gölä,
wie man es besser macht:
zuerst von oben
und dann von unten nach oben.
Ja, da sieht man den Profi.
Warte, das muss ich ausprobieren!
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Scheisse!
Nach vorne! Nach vorne!
Verdammter Mist!
Du hast dich
zu wenig weit nach vorne gebeugt.
Deshalb spickte es die Säge zurück.
Und jetzt
ist er noch nicht ganz durch.
Ja, ich weiss.
Ach!
Du kannst einfach ... Jawohl.
Siehst du?
Aber du hast dich vorhin
so geil durchgesägt.
Das kann ich nicht. Warum nicht?
- Und du solltest darauf achten,
dass dies einen Winkel gibt,
sonst sieht das aus ...
Ich kann mich nicht auf alles
gleichzeitig konzentrieren.
Sei nicht so streng mit mir,
verdammt!
Aber auch Hermanns Superschnitt
funktioniert nicht immer.
Himmel, Arsch und Zwirn!
- Schau!
Was?
Jetzt haben wir einen anderen Fall:
Er liegt dort nicht mehr auf.
Das hast du mir aber nicht gesagt.
Du hast selbst zwei Augen
und ein Hirn.
So ein Scheissdreck!
Also, hebe ihn hinten hoch!
Warte!
Gut?
- Ja.
* Rockmusik *
Holzerkurs bei Schönbächler -
das ist geil.
Brennholz gibt es jetzt genug.
* Rockmusik *
Hasta la vista, baby!
* Gölä lacht. *
Aua, mein Steissbein!
* Rockmusik *
So! Haltet euch fest!
- Schneller!
Festhalten!
Yeehaw!
* Sanfte Musik *
Juhu!
Gut! Gut!
Es wird langsam Abend.
Die viele Action hat Hunger gemacht.
Und dann ... Na dann hat Gölä
noch etwas zum Einlösen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wie sagte Hermann?
Gitarre spielen könne Gölä besser
als Bäume fällen.
Und das zeigt er jetzt -
live am Lagerfeuer.
Was haben wir jetzt? 20 Jahre Gölä,
zehn Jahre "Auf und davon".
Warum hat es bei dir
mit dem Auswandern nicht geklappt?
Du redest ja ständig davon
und hast es auch schon versucht.
Na ja, es ist eben noch ...
Ich glaube, ich bin gar nicht
so einfach, wie ich dachte.
Das letzte Mal fasste ich einen Job
auf den Seychellen.
Dort war es mir zu heiss.
Und dann ...
Ja, es ist wahr! Nachher gehe ich
an einen Ort, wo es mir zu kalt ist.
Vielleicht bin ich eine Memme.
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Aber ich suche noch
das richtige Klima.
Ja.
- Gut!
Singen wir dieses Liedchen.
One, two, one, two, three!
- Viel zu schnell!
Entschuldigung!
# Tue ig am Morge d'Fäischter uf,
# isch aues grau u nass.
# Me gseht keni Mönsche meh.
# Nume no Schirme
schuene dür d'Gass.
# Dr Himmu vou Wouche.
# U äs rägnet, was es abe mah.
# S'git Lüüt,
di göh wiit wäg vo hie.
# Am liebschte würd i mit ne gah.
# U si stige in Flüger,
flüged mit de Vögu furt.
# Chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie alles zrüg,
uf dr Suechi für nes nois Dihei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Eifach uf u dervo.
# De stige'ni i ds'Outo i.
# U bi im Morgeverchehr.
# Itz lueg emau di Gringe a.
# Chönntsch meine,
s'heig e jede es Gwehr.
# Nei, da gsehsch niene es Lache.
# U niene
gsehsch äs fründlechs Gsicht.
# Wie gärn
gieng i jetzt wäg vo hier.
# Aber das isch en anderi Gschicht.
# U si stige in Flüger,
flüged mit de Vögu furt.
# Chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie alles zrüg,
uf dr Suechi für nes nois Dihei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Sit zäh Jahr "Auf und davon".
* Lachen *
Das hat er improvisiert.
puretype gmbh / UT-Redaktion Zug
Im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2019
Ich brauche ihn zum Anzählen,
aber ich schaffe es auch ohne.
Drei, vier, und ...
# U si stige in Flüger,
flüged mit de Vögu furt.
# Chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie alles zrüg,
uf dr Suechi für nes nois Dihei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Zäh Jahr "Auf und davon".
* Lachen und Applaus *
Sie wandern aus oder kennen jemanden,
der auswandert?
Ein wunderschönes Gefühl!
"Auf und davon" sucht Menschen,
die sich bei ihrem grossen Abenteuer
begleiten lassen.
Schreiben Sie an: